[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
is the Tony Michaels podcast real and
raw political and social commentary the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty you [ __ ] eating
[ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of speech
this is the Tony Michaels podcast and
this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
it's Friday and you can't get into
Twitter spaces
[Music]
he's such a little [ __ ] isn't he what a
punk ass little [ __ ] you cry baby
[ __ ] this is ridiculous okay
we're gonna talk about freedom of speech
again today on the Tony Michaels podcast
and the reason why is because the right
wing clearly does not understand the
freedom of speech they clearly do not
understand they don't understand the
freedom of press which is actually a
freedom that is in the Constitution
yeah
it is in the Constitution
yeah
and of course they're all saying oh well
you said you said liberal that it's a
private platform and they get to do
whatever they want and they get to
cancel anybody yeah they do Elon Does
Elon absolutely I okay Aaron rupart uh
who posts a lot of videos that we play
here on the show
clips that I show you every [ __ ] day
he posts them him Ace and Ron there's
several other accounts
that are watching these right wing
morons and making sure that they shed
daylight on it and I try to spread that
around here on the Tony Michaels podcast
and give you my commentary of it because
it's important not just to see the clip
but no to know what to
the context is
because these these right Wingers like
Elon Musk Donald Trump and Kanye West
and the and the likes of them
are [ __ ] lying Nazis that's what they
are
pretty simple
it's a private platform and yesterday
when they when he started to suspend
journalists I'm not mad I'm not [ __ ]
pissed off if you think you're gonna
come here today and be like Oh Tony's so
mad that Elon kicked journalists off his
platform I'm not I don't give a [ __ ]
I don't I do not give a [ __ ] that he
suspended these accounts don't care I
don't care why I don't give a [ __ ] why I
don't I'm not gonna cry and whine about
why he did it it's his website it's his
he [ __ ] bought it
he's destroying it
and I'm all for him burning a the
biggest pile of money that he possibly
can burn because that's the only Power
he really has that's it
when he runs out of [ __ ] money Elon
Musk will be irrelevant just like Donald
Trump
we see yesterday the [ __ ] Donald
Trump Trading Card thing what a [ __ ]
joke people are pissed off that they
spent money on these things and they
can't even access them and and
unbeknownst to them they don't even own
the [ __ ] outright apparently if
they want to trade it or sell it back or
whatever
the the company which is sus gets part
of the [ __ ] profit anyway we're going
to talk about that later
Trump Trading Card thing again
seems like um a very coordinated uh scam
to put money in Trump's pocket oh who
would have thought that
but back to freedom of speech
because people like Elon and the others
don't understand what the [ __ ] freedom
is you don't get it
this idea this stupid [ __ ] ID on the
right with these Elon simps that somehow
he was gonna bring back freedom of
speech because of Twitter listen listen
to me when I tell you this you stupid
little [ __ ]
freedom of speech has nothing to do with
Twitter and Twitter has nothing to do
with freedom of speech not a God damn
thing it doesn't have anything to do
with it
you fundamentally do not understand
freedom of speech if you are if you are
a this morning cheering that Elon
journalist off of Twitter
be mad because Elon kicked them off his
website
and see
three I don't know one two three ABC
you do not understand the freedom of
speech
if you cannot figure out
that your freedom and your rights are
penned to the Constitution not to terms
of service
think about it
think about it
the terms of service that you've agreed
to to be a user on a website has nothing
to do with your freedom of speech not a
God damn thing
and I've I've watched journalists be
pissed off this morning on media oh my
God it's so egregious why why it's his
website now am I defending Elon no
because elon's such a [ __ ] idiot he
said the reason why I want this website
is to bring back freedom of speech to
Twitter and he does the exact opposite
of course because he's a [ __ ] Cuban
honor
when can we as a collective pluck our
heads out of our asses and realize what
the [ __ ] is going on
journalist hey journalist out there stop
bitching about your account being
suspended or someone else's account
being suspended on Twitter do your
[ __ ] job
and Elon when when the Press is doing
their job reporting on you quit being
such a goddamn [ __ ] quit being such a
[ __ ] snowflake if you believe in
freedom of speech then believe in it or
whatever you want to do [ __ ] my
suggestion is you [ __ ] is to put down
the [ __ ] machine hire back all your
[ __ ] employees at Twitter and let
them run that [ __ ]
and you go pretend that you invented
electricity or some [ __ ]
this is the dumbest [ __ ] I've ever seen
the whole [ __ ] uh Twitter is just a
garbage dump now
and this morning he charged I don't know
his last tweet he thought Twitter's hot
dude you are a dumb [ __ ]
he had to shut down Twitter spaces
yesterday because of freedom of speech
laughs
literally it's the exact opposite
yesterday he suspended journalist
accounts okay several journalists who
were reporting on him and some of them
are that that's their job like they're
assigned to report on Tech they were
signed to report on Twitter if something
big happens it's [ __ ] news
so they report on it
he was pissed off because there's a
public website out there that links to
the location of his [ __ ] jet it's
really stupid [ __ ] it it's public
information when you own a private
[ __ ] jet Elon
that they get the tail number and they
can track you dummy you knew that buying
a private jet you [ __ ] idiot
Flight commercial
you dumb [ __ ]
it's really stupid ass [ __ ] when these
motherf this is the same stupid [ __ ]
that they these [ __ ] right-wingers
complain I lost my job because I
wouldn't get vaccinated yeah they told
you get vaccinated or you don't have a
job here choose [ __ ] and you chose
Elon Musk chooses to [ __ ] buy a
private jet and fly that [ __ ]
all around
he chooses that
I don't have the [ __ ] choice of a
private jet most of you I know all of
you probably most of you do not have the
choice of a private jet [ __ ] some of you
probably don't even have the [ __ ]
money to scrape together
to [ __ ] even fly
this holiday season because of [ __ ]
[ __ ] bags like Elon Musk
it's it's just dumb ass [ __ ]
and look you can you can give me the
whole freedom of press and all that and
it's constitutional yeah it is it's in
the Constitution but they ain't got
nothing to do with the terms and service
of Twitter
it's this [ __ ] idiot that gets to
determine that from here on out if
you're not okay with it go somewhere
else and adhere to their terms of
service
unless he's actually violating the
Constitution which suspending someone's
account for what he wants to suspend
them for it's probably not a violation
of the Constitution I just don't see a
court of law going why the [ __ ] do you
think it's a violation for for someone
not to have an account on a [ __ ]
website it makes no sense it's not a
public utility it's not it won't be and
we can't get Congress to agree that
social media is a form of News until we
get there we it's just not going to
happen
I mean I think we need to have more
oversight on social media
and if if one individual wants to own a
social media website like Elon Musk owns
Twitter their balls are in a ringer
constantly should be
but that's not where we're at yet we are
not there yet
Elon knows that the right wing knows
that Putin knows that the Saudis know
that that's why they gave him the money
to buy the [ __ ] website that's why
they knew he would destroy this thing
they knew he would destroy this [ __ ]
thing there's no better there's no
better world to live in for fascists
than a than a state of Chaos
especially when you're trying to talk
about freedoms and rights and equality
and equity
chaos is their friend
why do you think you let all the [ __ ]
Nazis back on Twitter
I don't think it's because Elon
fundamentally
believes that he's a Nazi
I mean he's a fascist for sure
I don't think he's you know
it's not in the Forefront
you know it's programming in the
background running that [ __ ] he's
Superior he's better than you he's
smarter than you
[ __ ] bitching because he bought
a private jet that he knows can be
tracked
and this idea that somehow because they
can track your plane
means that there's an assassination plot
against you is the dumbest [ __ ] thing
I've ever heard in my life and we we've
heard of a lot we heard a lot of dumb
[ __ ] this week
a lot of dumb [ __ ] Kevin McCarthy's
gonna go have hearings at the border
Lauren bobert wants wants to impeach the
DHS secretary because he's doing his job
this is really stupid [ __ ]
but here we are
again at the [ __ ] conversation of
freedom of speech because people just
don't fundamentally understand it
and what it means and until we really
truly do as a collective understand
freedoms and rights
that they are the vehicle
that delivered us that and delivers US
future Liberty
we do not strive for freedom and rights
we don't strive for those things
the freedom and rights Deliver us the
liberty
in which we strive in a democracy
until we get our [ __ ] heads wrapped
around that we are going to continue to
do this stupid [ __ ] because again I'm
not a fan of Aaron not being on Twitter
frankly this show needs the clips
we need Eclipse to show you
we rely on accounts like Aaron
to make sure they're putting their thumb
on on what people are doing and what
they're saying because it's influence
and in today's world there's so much of
it it's hard to keep track
and he's One account that does it the
same way these other journalists who get
suspended keep track and keep tabs on
what the [ __ ] Elon Musk is doing so we
know
Congress has oversight of the government
and the Executive Branch the judicial
branch
the Press has oversight over everything
it's the whole point
what do you what do you think the
daylight of the press is that's the
whole concept is daylight is the best
disinfectant
the Press has delivered us our modern
democracy regardless of what Elon Musk
or anybody else on the right wing want
to think
and today's media is it's really shitty
there's a few good journalists Aaron's
one of them but am I mad that he's
suspended no
do I give a [ __ ] that he doesn't have
his account on Twitter no how could I I
can't control that [ __ ] what am I gonna
do
and you say well that that hampers
freedom and rights no it doesn't it only
points out
the obvious
that's what we need
so Elon is suspending these journalists
he's not doing himself a favor by a for
a few days
making it to where his Jet's location
isn't on Twitter which it doesn't matter
if it's on Twitter or not you can go
look it up somewhere else you [ __ ]
idiot
and he knew that when he bought the jet
he knew that that the tail number is
trapped
it's not [ __ ] rocket science
he chose this
he chose it
the same [ __ ] who mocked a real
assassination attempt in San Francisco
on Nancy Pelosi when that [ __ ] mother
freak broke into their house and bashed
her husband in his head in with a hammer
how about that Elon you dumb
[ __ ]
because that's really the story here is
is the right wing is so [ __ ] wrapped
up in their own selfish wants and white
supremacist needs
they're consumed by it
that's why I was so [ __ ] disappointed
that Dave Chappelle put that
[ __ ] on stage did it was it a
great moment for Elon no did it make him
look like a fool of course
yeah
but at what expense
but you know what that's Dave
Chappelle's stage
and I could criticize and comment on it
but it's Dave Chappelle's stage folks
and if you want Liberty if you want
Liberty if that's truly what you want in
your democracy everybody else has got to
have Liberty too even the guy who is
burning [ __ ] cash
like crazy just to keep Twitter open
because that's that's why he's [ __ ]
spiraling here you understand that right
he's he's likely he's likely to lose
Tesla
he's selling shares like it's going out
of style just to keep the [ __ ] lights
on at Twitter he can't pay rent at
Twitter he can't pay the [ __ ]
Severance packages because he fired
everybody and didn't [ __ ] consider
how much money he was gonna have to pay
in Severance packages he's gonna get
sued for the [ __ ] money
they're gonna win
he's not gonna win those [ __ ]
Severance lawsuits he's not
the state of California has some of the
most stringent laws in that in that area
of the law
he's [ __ ] on that front
and he's bound to lose Tesla
and Tesla was already on the ropes
anyways and the reason why is because
American and foreign car manufacturers
who have dealerships in this country are
catching up with EBS
and the market doesn't give a [ __ ] about
the autonomy driving they don't give a
[ __ ] they just don't want their car to
catch on fire
and they don't want it to look like [ __ ]
no one wants that cyber truck that thing
looks stupid I don't give a [ __ ] who you
are what you say that cyber truck looks
[ __ ] dumb it's stupid looking
it's not a good design it looks like
[ __ ] it doesn't even look like a [ __ ]
truck
this is America you bonehead
you're going to try to sell something
that looks like that to people who want
a truck try making it look like I don't
know a [ __ ] pickup truck like GM and
[ __ ] Ford are doing
they're gonna win
the Cyber truck the EV truck
Ford and Chevrolet are gonna win that
market [ __ ]
you better well guarantee that I don't
give a [ __ ] how smart Elon thinks he is
there's no [ __ ] way Tesla is ever
gonna box out Ford and Chevrolet in the
pickup truck Market in this country it
just is not gonna happen
and when the consumer finds out that the
[ __ ] truck looks the same drives the
same has the same towing capacity as a
regular half ton pickup
and they don't have to buy fuel they
just plug the [ __ ] in
and they have the infrastructure in
place which the Democrats are delivering
not Republicans by the way
Elon
you you think you think Tesla is going
to win the truck battle with that piece
of [ __ ]
look you can say whatever you want about
the the Trump people with their pickup
trucks and all that stuff right like we
can go on this political rant about
pickup trucks but pickup trucks in
general the market for pickup trucks
there's a reason why they look the way
they look okay there's a reason why Ford
and Chevrolet spend gazillions of
dollars and tons of energy labor and
time
of figuring out the design of the truck
it ain't got nothing to do with what
Elon wants not a goddamn thing and Elon
is no he
he is no trendsetter
he buys Trends he doesn't make them
he bought a shitload of Trends on
Twitter and they suck now
that's what he does
it's what he does
sorry to say he's not that smart you
Elon sense he's a dumb [ __ ]
and in your argument that he was the
richest man in the world and that's how
he's going to deliver us free speech you
just lost that one and you're about to
lose even more on that front
he just sold I don't know 32 33 billion
dollars worth of Tesla stock I don't
know just to keep the [ __ ] lights on
how in the [ __ ] does the richest man in
the world lose his fortune you're
talking about
he was gonna be
the first trillionaire folks do you know
how much [ __ ] money a trillion is do
you have any do you have any idea how
big of a number trillion is
it is almost [ __ ] impossible
to even imagine
that someone who is a trillionaire would
go [ __ ] flat broke
but you're watching it right out in the
open
and [ __ ] can't even handle
he can't even handle
his tail number on his plane his private
plane being tracked
look just because they're tracking your
plane dummy doesn't mean you're in it it
doesn't mean it they're giving away your
location they're giving the location of
your plane
which you chose when you bought the
[ __ ]
this is really dumb [ __ ]
but on the other side of the coin when
people are mad because he's suspending
people on his website folks that's
stupid too it's dumb
you can yell you can scream but if
you're mad about Aaron losing and I'd
say Aaron because we use a lot of his
his content here there were several
other journalists that were that were um
suspended for reporting on Elon
and and Reporting on this that this
airplane story where he thinks it's
assassination plot that someone posts a
link on Twitter of a public domain
somewhere that tracks not just his plane
but all planes it's really dumb stupid
[ __ ]
you bought the plane you knew it was
gonna be trapped
and if you didn't know it sell the
[ __ ]
sell the [ __ ]
you make Vehicles don't you they [ __ ]
drive there's highways everywhere drive
a [ __ ] Tesla around you dumb son of a
[ __ ]
foreign
how they drive themselves they catch on
fire themselves too I hear but you know
whatever you want to do man it's your
choice you are making these choices
it's called freedom
it's called freedom
and freedom and rights is what delivers
us our Liberty
and we do not have to stand around
acting like the freedom of speech is
something that it's not acting like the
freedom of press is something that's not
foreign
and the other journalists Sue Twitter
under the guise of freedom of the press
but I doubt that works
I doubt it works
Aaron and the rest of the journalists
can go report somewhere else on Twitter
without having to post on Twitter
Aaron's got a sub stack you should go
follow it
go follow Aaron's sub stack sure why not
if if you want to see Aaron's reporting
he has a sub stack
as long as they'll let him keep it
maybe you'll have to open up his own
website to post a blog look folks
until we all get on the same page of
what Liberty freedom is we are not gonna
[ __ ] be in a situation where we can
get rid and get these right-wing Nazis
to crawl back underneath their [ __ ]
rocks
and we have to mock them at every turn
but we can't we can't set ourselves up
to be mocked
journalist this morning oh it's a
[ __ ] egregious that Aaron Rupert
doesn't have a [ __ ] Twitter look
there's a lot of journalists that don't
have a Twitter it's not a requirement to
be a journalist to have a Twitter
account that's got 750 000 followers
it's not a requirement
it's not
does it help to get your message out
sure sure it does
but folks that's up to you
you consuming the content that you want
to consume in the time that you have to
consume it
and to make sure you're using it to the
the biggest advantage of your Liberty as
you possibly can that's your choice
and if you're sitting around eating
Cheetos watching sitcoms and football
you're not you're not I mean you know
you might be entertained
sure I mean fine yeah I mean I I like to
watch sitcoms every once in a while too
and sports
but it does not help me advance my
[ __ ] Liberty
your freedom of choice has nothing to do
with how many frozen pizzas are in the
freezer aisle in the grocery store
it doesn't
it doesn't it's nothing to do with
freedom that has nothing to do with it
how many frozen pizzas you get to choose
between
so
when you go into the weekend here
it's getting close to the holiday season
everything's gonna get mushed around
and on Monday
we have a big hearing
speaking of democracy there's going to
be a big hearing on Monday with the
January 6 select committee
um we're not really sure exactly what
it's going to be yet
hopefully we'll hear something more
today or tomorrow over the weekend of
exactly what they're going to do on
Monday
but it looks like they're going to be
giving criminal referrals
for the people who tried to overthrow
our democracy overthrow our Liberty
dunk our freedom into the [ __ ] trash
by overturning our vote
there's nothing more important than that
there should be way more outrage that
these [ __ ] America First Nazis
tried to steal away our democracy
because their butt hurt and their man
they're just they're sad that the man
baby down at Mar-A-Lago didn't win
he's a loser
and they didn't get their way
and they're going to give criminal
referrals on Monday
I would suspect because they're setting
this up to be an event
that Donald Trump and a criminal
referral are going to be in that hearing
now we're not sure how long it's going
to be I mean I you know if I'm guessing
they're probably going to give some sort
of uh
a
recap
of the previous
hearings
but this will be what we suspect to be
the final hearing because on Wednesday
they're gonna they're going to release
the uh final report and it doesn't look
like they're doing a hearing for that
they may but it doesn't look like it
so Monday is a very important day in our
democracy
because the action
is what will matter from the select
committee now does it make a difference
as far as the doj no
the doj does not give a [ __ ]
if the select committee gives referrals
or not they don't give a [ __ ] they don't
care
they don't need no [ __ ] referral from
the [ __ ] from Congress
to investigate crimes that's not
something the doj has to have it's not a
prerequisite of them indicting Trump or
his allies in the coup attempt
but it's the messaging it's the
narrative folks it's what I talk about
every day here why it's so important to
watch shows like this
and I know that benefits me but it is
important that you know the national
narrative we had racial bidikoffer on
yesterday
in my opinion the best political
strategist in the country my favorite
not just because she uses the f word
because she understands what's at stake
she knows the fight we're in
and I believe Liz Cheney and Benny
Thompson and the rest of the select
committee know the fight we're in
and they have to send a message on the
official Congressional Record
that the former president United States
Donald Trump tried to commit a coup
he tried to obstruct our vote he tried
to stop our democracy he tried to tear
up our constitution
the thing that that embodies the rights
and the freedoms to deliver you the
Liberty that you so seek
so until we get our heads wrapped around
what these things actually are
then we will continue the nonsense
that it's happening on Twitter last
night and today
and it is [ __ ] nonsense drivel
when it comes to what is important
and what we must focus on and I know I
made it the [ __ ] you know the the
thumbnail
and the title and that's to get you to
come here and [ __ ] listen to the
actual problem to the actual messaging
see the actual narrative
and you do every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific right here on YouTube Twitter
and twitch today's Friday you know what
that means bonehead of the week
we're going to break it down in the
second hour me and Gabe Sanchez I think
he's still trying to figure out who the
alpha guck and DM is he's uh working
hard over there on the graphics so I
don't know if maybe you'll join me uh
just for bonehead and we'll get him on
here but go follow at Tony Michaels pod
you can vote there every single week for
bonehead of the week
and then we break it down every single
Friday you can also vote on YouTube so
while you're here on YouTube
subscribe to the Tony Michaels podcast
you can go to the community Tab and you
can vote there for bonehead of the week
don't forget to download every single
episode Monday through Friday on Apple's
Spotify Google you can also download
bonehead of the week in and of itself on
Sundays
on Apple Spotify you go make sure to
leave a great review while you're
subscribing to your favorite directory
to download the podcast on also if
you're on Facebook you're probably
watching this on Midas Touch page you
might be watching on my page but go
follow at the Tony Michaels on Facebook
and you can follow us on Twitch as well
the Tony Michaels twitch.tv slash the
Tony Michaels you can download the app
just search anywhere
search anywhere the Tony Michaels the
Tony Michaels podcast you will find this
show
it's a worldwide show as a matter of
fact people watch all around the world
and we talk about National politics here
but people are very concerned about what
is going on in America
all around the world they are and you're
the best audience in the world
you give us such great support here and
to support us just go to Tony Michaels
dot live and give a one-time tip there
you can set it up monthly set it and
forget it
you'd like to support the show and
support the content we appreciate every
bit of your support
rather you are rather you are giving
tips or you're going to the merch store
store.thedonymichaels.com and checking
out all of our Liberty merch there it's
stored.dtonymichaels.com or you were
just here
listening sharing commenting chatting
in the live chat we appreciate all the
support
it's very important to
Free Speech Elon is very important
that you listen to pro-democracy speech
without pro-democracy speech they want
to drown us out that's what this really
is all about
it's what it's really all about this
freedom of speech [ __ ] it's always
projection with them they want they want
the freedom to stop our speech is what
they want
that's what they want they want to
cancel us that's why they're always
bitching about cancer culture
because they want they're projecting
what they want to do
to us liberals that's right
liberalism is the strength of democracy
that's why they want to tear it down
to make democracy weak and we shall not
let them do that
so come listen every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central for two full hours here on the
Tony Michaels podcast
we're gonna get to the bonehead of the
week in the second hour as we do every
Friday you vote for bone of the week you
decide we break it down in the second
hour but before that I got some stuff I
want to show you everyone stick around
we'll be right back right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Maga
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon I was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the words that I'm struggling with I
chose Babel mag Edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now I can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new Mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
foreign
podcast
welcome back to the show
we went out and got them some Trump
trading cards yesterday
they're [ __ ] sold out quote sold out
45
000 of them I guess
they're really leaning into the number
45 they were leaning into the 47 too on
some of those remember we showed him
yesterday some of them had you know his
[ __ ] idiot acting like he was tough
and [ __ ] he's some kind of superhero no
some of them said 45 some of them said
47.
I can't wait I can't wait in 2028 to see
who
the 47th president is my guess is it's
not going to be Donald Trump
[Laughter]
what a [ __ ] idiot these people really
are stupid apparently they can't they
can't get the the the trading cards or
the nfts as it were is the I guess the
official name of them
and there was 45
000 they sold out on the website
apparently you did not get to pick them
we didn't understand that the other day
when we were looking at the website we
were looking at the website the other
day trying to figure out what the hell
this [ __ ] was
trying to figure out this shit's legal
or not course A lot of it seems sus
and I'm sure I'm sure
um there's going to be more reporting on
it because it seems like I don't know a
fraud anything anything Donald Trump
touches turns to liquid [ __ ]
so of course this is going to turn the
liquid [ __ ]
and there's probably going to be crime
involved
there's definitely
um an aspect of him trying to launder
money I'm sure
sure of it I'm sure of it
yeah apparently he sold all 45
000 that they had in inventory
and he raised I don't know four and a
half million dollars through this um
this dis company
and while we didn't fully understand the
other day because we were laughing so
[ __ ] hard at the commercial and then
trying to figure out on the website how
you even buy this thing or get the uh
get entered in the sweepstakes to win
the prizes
we were trying to figure that out how
that how the legality of that
and it seems as if
um he licensed his name to a company
okay
so this nft company whoever the in the
sweepstakes company
he may or may not own those companies
and he's licensing them but it seems
really strange
people were pointing it out that the
address on the website for the um the
nft company is the same address as one
of his golf course courses in Palm Beach
seems kind of sus doesn't it doesn't
seem kind of suspicious it's almost like
if he licensed his name he licensed it
to himself
and he's trying to I don't know steal
money it just feels like that I don't
know but let's take a look in the
shitless Roundup everybody let's round
up all the Tweety tweets and the trendy
trends of the day before we go to Bone
end of the week start the countdown
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome welcome back to the show you
have reached the part where we round up
all the Tweety tweets and journey Trends
I just want to go um Hassan [ __ ]
has a tweet here that I want to show
everybody oh I'm on the wrong I'm on the
wrong [ __ ] one I'm on the wrong
tab here we go we'll just go down there
it is
Hassan writes oh well maybe he says
Twitter Trends have been absolute dog
[ __ ] since Elon took over this is
absolutely true
what if I mean that that is the that was
the consistency sort of or the
reliability of Twitter before
is that you know generally speaking the
trends were showing what the what
trending news was out there you go to
the Twitter Trends and you can find what
the the world was talking about in the
news now it's just what what Twitter's
talking about on Twitter
so he says the Twitter Trends have been
absolute dog [ __ ] since Elon took over
which is absolutely true
um and I even said it makes the [ __ ]
list even shittier
hmm who'd have thought who'd have took
it who'd have dunk it you can get my
keyboard here okay
now I got them another one I want to
show you uh of this uh nft thing
so the
um yesterday we we went through a couple
of the nfts if I can open there we go
look at this one
all right so the first one is uh from
the video do you remember that the uh
the teaser video that we showed you
um I mean I don't know if you
which one's worse the teaser video or
the actual
um the infomercial that he he's
abruptly recorded
but here is here's the the laser
eyeballs he's trying to do the whole
Trump's trying to do the whole dark
Brandon thing he's really jealous
that uh
that all the dark Brandon [ __ ] that we
put on the internet the left is put on
the internet
yeah he's really pissed off that makes
Jill Biden look cool I think that's what
this all is is more jealousy than money
making
but you know he'll turn anything into a
grift absolutely anything
but this one over here is really [ __ ]
weird right so you see it's got the
American flag in the back they all got
the [ __ ] American leg somewhere but
he's got the American flag at the back
he does not have a red tie on in this
one
um he is not this skinny of course now
they did do a pretty good job at the
baggy [ __ ] pants right
I'm surprised I didn't slim fit him but
he wears these [ __ ] he wears these
goddamn pants that have huge [ __ ] um
pant legs at the bottom the reason why
is to hide that he's wearing high-heeled
shoes
I'm not [ __ ] you that's why he wears
them
that's why everything's for a reason
when you see this [ __ ]
everything's for a reason and the reason
why he wears these baggy ass big ass
[ __ ] pants with the big ass legs and
so they cover the high heels he wears
heels folks
I don't know I don't know if Trump
supporters know this or not but their
dude is in Drag
um
they're always bitching about drag shows
this guy this guy [ __ ] dies his hair
he wears makeup
he wears a corset to make him look
skinnier to change his body type or try
to change his body type
he wears modified shoots to make him
look taller and skinnier and he wears
modified suits with big ass pant legs to
cover his heels
I'm not saying a dude shouldn't wear
heels I'm not [ __ ] not against it
whatever you want to do I don't care if
you want to wear actual heels like Marco
Rubio does and Ted Cruz or you want to
wear heels with lifts in the shoes I
don't give a [ __ ] whatever you want to
do man whatever floats your boat how I
wouldn't care if Donald Trump put on a
[ __ ] pair of fishnets and some
lingerie I don't give a [ __ ] I mean I
wouldn't want to look at it but whatever
he wants to do
whatever
just don't act like he ain't doing this
[ __ ] but I digress from that but look at
this picture look at the Statue of
Liberty back here he is thumbs upping he
is really excited
that our Lady Liberty is in the dark
isn't that weird this one feels really
[ __ ] weird to me
right
am I just am I off my rocker to think
that this one is patriotic because just
because it has the American flag in the
background
is it just me
because when I saw this one this morning
that's the reason why I retweeted this
this tweet from Mike
is this image here of this nft that the
trading card which they're not really
trading cards
um I grew up in the 90s okay Michael
Jordan was very um popular in 90s if you
don't remember and I collected and I
still have a whole collection of
basketball cards that was a big Michael
Jordan fan big Chicago Bulls fan of
course and I collected a lot of Michael
Jordan cards Scottie Pippen Michael
Jordan
Steve Kerr Horace Grant you know all the
Bulls right
and trading the trading cards then
didn't look like they that's not they
actually had like borders around them
they had the name the position sometimes
it was like a special edition where it'd
be like a defensive of the year or
offense of the year you know something
like that
it depended on the actual series of the
trading guards
but these aren't trading cards
that's not they don't even look like
trading cards and I forgot to point that
out the other day
that these are just [ __ ] AI images
they're just shitty [ __ ] images and
apparently you can't even get your image
because it's all random when you buy it
right so you may want this one here
right the one with the [ __ ] laser
eyes where he's trying to compete with
dark Brandon because he's [ __ ]
inadequate and inept
and doesn't understand that Joe Biden
doesn't give a [ __ ] what memes are made
about him but Donald Trump clearly gives
a [ __ ] what memes are made of him and
then this one over here so you don't you
know you may want this one but you get
this one over here where he's he's
putting Lady Liberty in the dark
and he's and he's really happy about it
yeah
like it's a desert
a freedom and I'm excited woohoo I want
to be the dictator in the king that's
really [ __ ] weird [ __ ] but um here's
the uh here's the actual tweet by Mike
and he said who bought these Trump's
digital trading guards quote unquote
that's what I would put around it have
sold out all 45 000 of the 99 each it
means you raise four point
four or five million so four and a half
million dollars in just 12 hours
hmm
seems kind of suspicious
I think do you do you think there's I
now I said I said I said the other day
when we were talking about this that I
bet people are dipping into their
[ __ ] home's equity
dipping into their home's Equity to buy
these things I believe they are
these people are [ __ ] weird man
they'll do some crazy [ __ ] for the cult
crazy ass [ __ ] for the cult
so why wouldn't we believe that they do
this
I don't know man I'm just saying
okay
let's see what oh oh here's a great nft
Tweet now yesterday or the other day
when we were um talking about this I
said someone needs to make nfts of what
Trump actually looks like
um here's Jason from from the good liars
he said nfts are [ __ ] stupid we made
some mfts honest trumpcards.com so you
can go to honestrompcards.com here's one
of them
well there's there's an honest Trump nft
in it yeah holy [ __ ] poor guy
he's so sad he's got a Dunlap it's where
your belly done lamped over your belt
[Music]
oh boy so I mean you know
I guess someone was listening the other
day when I said someone should make uh
some honest ones
so they they got honesttrumpcards.com
and again they say nfts are [ __ ]
stupid so
which
if you haven't figured that out in this
whole [ __ ] Saga of trump trading
cards which is going to continue because
I'm almost sure I'm almost positive
that Donald Trump is using this to
launder money somehow
and and what what I mean by that
is that he's using this this company
um with the same address which is a
thing that really seems suss here
the same address as his golf course
in Palm Beach
okay I I do want to point this out
um Angry Stamper brings up a good point
here
and this is an important tweet and we
need to keep talking about this
as they as they the Republicans take the
house and start assigning [ __ ]
committees for the hunter Biden lamped
up sham investigation
um swingers Jennifer says so those
Meadows text message Texas Texas
are pretty bad for a lot of people yeah
they're the yeah they are whoosh 34
members of Congress are now under a
microscope of the coup it's everything
the GOP one and Hunter Biden's laptop to
be that is right
[ __ ] kind of mine's lamped up we need to
see Mark Meadow's phone
I want Mark Meadow's phone and I want it
now where is it let's investigate the
[ __ ] out of it
but of course we're going to get a bunch
of [ __ ] committees I forget who was it
and does anybody know who it was in the
chat that said Kaka minis I gotta thank
them
that was fantastic
that was fantastic
um [ __ ] committees someone came up with
that that it was the date you remember
the day where we were um
where Elon was upset
and they thought it was big news that
Twitter wouldn't let non-consented
photos of Hunter Biden's [ __ ] onto
Twitter you remember this they really
thought it was a big deal that Twitter
took down
dick pics of Hunter Biden because he
didn't consent to them being on a
website and they were really upset that
the Biden the Biden campaign was allowed
allowed to report these tweets which
anyone's allowed to report any tweet
it's I mean
still maybe not in the future
you know you may you may you may have to
be a Nazi to actually have to report a
tweet that hurts your feelings and I bet
that's what it's going to come down to
is eventually we're gonna have because
he shut down Twitter spaces and we'll
talk about that in the um in the
bonehead of the week
but he shut down Twitter spaces because
he couldn't handle a few questions
because he's such a [ __ ] snowflake
uh Elon that is but I would bet that
eventually when you go report a tweet
it's going to be like something like um
because it asks you a few questions and
ask you to like categorize what your
what you're reporting it for it'll be
like are you a Nazi yes no and you know
you'll have to click yes to go forward
because if you say no uh nope no we
don't want you reporting anything then
must be one of them liberal left Wingers
that want to silence our intolerance
silence our bigotry silence our racism
that's what you are if you're not a Nazi
so you're probably selective you're a
Nazi or not and then what will happen is
it'll be like
did this tweet hurt your feelings
yes or no
and then it'll probably give you like a
maybe it'll be like a poll like Elon has
he always does these polls which
yesterday we're going to get into that
you fail on a pole or it'll be like on a
range one to ten you know when you go on
the doctor and like how's your pain
level is it is it oh is it tears running
down your face
so to Brad be like does this tweet hurt
your feelings yes will be the only
answer that you can there will be no no
it'd just be yes and then you'll have to
gauge it on the on the crying scale the
snowflake scale
and then that's how that's how the your
report tweet
in the days to come I'm sure that's
something that they're working on over
Twitter as we speak
to make sure of that
um I got another video I want you to
watch though
you guys know JoJo from Jersey if it's a
friend of the show and she has this
character named Becky Sue
and we've actually had Becky Sue in a
few of our little bits that we've done
but I love I love the character Becky
Sue but apparently Becky Sue
bought some nfts she's not really sure
what nfts are she doesn't even know that
you're supposed to say nft
want to listen
hey y'all it's me Becky Sue here doing
my daily video Vlog update for y'all so
I have a very exciting update today I
just bought 10. Trump trading cards 10
of them one two three four five six
nine ten
I'm so excited about one for myself one
for my mama or my cousin Chet and and
just a whole bunch of other ones like
nine other ones or something to give out
as Christmas presents I'm so excited I
got myself the one of Trump Brian the
red white and blue elephant because that
really happened okay I think it was
either in like France or Ohio or simply
but it definitely happened okay so I got
myself that one and I got my mama one of
him riding a motorcycle out in outer
space and I'm just I'm so excited I
can't wait till they arrive but I did
have one question I can't quite figure
out so how do I get those nifts to stick
on my back bumper like do they stick by
themselves lick them or something are
they self at Heat at Heat at heat said
and he'd save or
um like their special kind of tape or
something like that because I just don't
know I get the nests out of my bumper
I'm sure that's easy as pie so y'all
going to put those in the comments
that'd be really great anyways I am so
excited I cannot wait well that's all
for today stay safe out there y'all bye
and get you some nips okay bye
foreign
[Music]
as always
um
[Music]
absolutely fantastic when when Becky Sue
gives uh
that this is some of these [ __ ]
yeah and some people are thinking that's
[ __ ] real that's not real that's JoJo
from jurors
um she um she
if you don't follow JoJo from Jersey on
Twitter go follow her I mean you still
can and she's got a newsletter too that
you can subscribe to and she's a friend
of the show here and I and and she's
she's been on the show as a guest and
Becky Sue that character it's a
character that she does
um has been on the show but don't you
know
that is in reality
in reality there's some people out there
that really viewed these Trump trading
cards and I mean they sold 45 000 of
them that's what they say right I mean
you know it
I I don't know if it's the truth I mean
I guess maybe we'll find out eventually
if they actually sold 45 000 of these
things I don't know who the [ __ ] would
buy them Becky's who definitely would
but there's people out there that would
buy these things and maybe that's the
thing because I think on the website
when we looked at it the other day you
can only purchase a hundred of them or
maybe it was a hundred of them
that you could get uh uh entry into the
sweepstakes so but I'm not sure maybe
you can only buy 100 of them and I'm not
sure what the limit was but there was 45
000 of them uh Red Wave of ketchup uh
brings up a good point he says 45 000
sounds like BS well it may sound it may
be [ __ ] I'm not I'm not gonna
disagree 45 000 that they sold may be of
absolute [ __ ]
but 45 is because he was the 45th
president that's why the 45 000. right
that's why
oh boy um here's some more um
I'm gonna show this here's some more
actual Trump nfts uh to make him look
like and the actual thing here's the
heights driver High Plains grifter
um space farce
top dumb
and then democracy killer super spam
oh so that one's great great
um and all he did was open up the
floodgates here
to mock him with the art more than
anything
but it is what it is oh here's another
one here we go couplander here's another
great um
Trump nft coolander look at that
very appropriate and that list goes on
and on and on here they're not going to
stop memeing this stuff for sure and
here's another great one it's uh you
know the art that Trump sees himself as
and what he actually looks like here
in a Superman outfit
so there's not going to be any short
supply of a trump trading guard memes
they're gonna continue a lot and he set
himself up for this right
and he totally set himself up to do this
and we're going to talk more about
whether it's a thing
um whether it's a
a scam or not a scam but like illegal
activity going on here in the uh
in the [ __ ] in the uh excuse me in the
bonehead of the week because we're gonna
have bone in the week I wonder if let's
see if Gabe Sanchez is
is um ready
I don't know we'll see if he's ready to
go here
um looks like we got some um
let's see why is Supreme Court Justices
trending is there something happening is
there breaking news out there
of Supreme Court Justices or something
it's starting to trend that's the first
time I've seen something that seems like
a news Trend that didn't have to do with
Elon and his dumb [ __ ] plane
um
yeah I'm not sure I'm not sure does
anybody know
is there some kind of Supreme Court
thing going on I don't know
trying to keep up this morning
okay and so we're gonna go to bonehead
of the week here soon once we get Gabe
Sanchez on here I'm gonna see if he's if
he's good um Margie Margie says she's
looking
you're looking cool uh send me a DM if
there is something I'll um I'll take a
look at it and see if there's something
going on you go we have the grand MJ's
here today too we have the greatest
moderators in the world now that I'm
thinking about it it's Friday I'm going
into the weekend everyone should give
great love to the moderators they do
such a great job here on the Tony
Michaels podcast
keeping everybody in shape some people
are wondering about fake Gabe
um over on Facebook and we had to we had
an 86 and he just he couldn't he
couldn't control himself which I I
figured he wouldn't be able to
um you know to some degree so he had a
86 and just had no other choice that
[ __ ] Nazi man I just I wanted I was
hoping what he would do was stay
would stay in line and just do the Trump
copy machine thing but he really he got
he got two out of hand and he was
reporting people and everything else
[ __ ] him so we got rid of him that's
what I'm saying freedom it's my page my
broadcast I get the [ __ ] I get the 86
you if I want but we do have the best
mods in the world so give them love give
them love in the comments and to all of
our moderators there
um
the other thing too is I want to remind
you again on Monday there is going to be
a hearing
the January 6th select committee is
going to do a public hearing to vote on
the criminal referrals we're not really
sure exactly who how many and all that
kind of [ __ ] right
so we're not really sure exactly we're
not sure how like how long it's going to
last it's going to be at uh one Eastern
but we'll start our coverage here and
the Midas Touch YouTube channel so you
can watch it because we'll start at all
regular time so the the Tony Michaels
podcast on Monday will be the select
hearing that's what it will be now we'll
have we'll have guests with us uh people
from the Midas touch Network to give
commentary
on the select hearing before and after
again we're not really sure exactly
exactly uh what what they're going to do
or how long it's going to take my guess
is and I've talked to a few people about
this I think I it seems like what
they'll do is some sort of recap
into what the referrals that they're
gonna make are right so they'll recap
some of the hearings and some of the
facts from the January 6
um insurrection
and then they'll make the referrals
based on those facts would be my guess
it could be though it could be very
abrupt uh Benny Thompson
um is very
um known for this that he's just all
business and it could be just like when
they referred the contempt charges I
don't know if you guys remember this
when they had hearings to do the
contempt charges uh for Peter Navarro
and Mark Meadows and Steve Bannon those
hearings were very short they just came
in gave the facts of why they're doing
the referral they did the referral voted
on it boom the the meeting was done
that could be what they do here too we
just don't know yet what's gonna happen
on Monday
um and then on Wednesday they're going
to release their final report they
really have to get this final report now
they're just not going to have enough
time next week they're going to be
leaving
Congress for the the holiday vacation
and they'll be back but they won't have
time to get this hearing in and release
this report
um after the holiday in between then and
the next Congress
when the next Congress gets sworn in so
they're up against a clock here
um MJ did you find anything on the
Supreme Court yeah let's see let me go
to my
um but so on Monday we will have the
hearing here we also have it over on
Midas Touch I'll be hosting the coverage
as I did for the rest of the hearings uh
me and Gabe Sanchez uh will be hosting
um that hearing as well since we did the
others for Midas Touch uh again we'll
have guests on I'm sure we'll have Texas
Paul I know David Bender uh is is going
to give some commentary and the my
zealous brothers are very likely to give
commentary maybe Michael Cohen that's
possible that we will have Jessica
Denson and some few others maybe even I
haven't talked to Lee but maybe politics
girl
um definitely going to see if she wants
to give commentary and we just don't
we're supposed to know more today
about like the timing we just don't
[ __ ] know and we're trying we're
trying to pry we're trying to figure out
what the [ __ ] they're gonna do so that
we know so that we can produce the show
right
um so we'll see how it goes but I I'm
sure I'm sure I'm sure um we'll get
we'll get plenty of the um
plenty of the Midas touch Network
commentators on I I'd also like to have
Dr Rachel bittickoffer what do you guys
think maybe I should ask Rachel I'll ask
her this afternoon if she can join us
afterwards because I'd like to get her
take on
when it's going to be after Gabe Sanchez
there you are hey [ __ ] how are
you today what's going on man it's
Friday it's Friday man I know it is
Friday Friday
it's Friday that's
a DM I haven't went and looked yet have
you have you figured those out I did you
did but I don't well you're probably
gonna see it when you bring it in let's
see I'm gonna go look at it and you
might you might laugh I did one of them
okay we've never done that before no I
didn't that's never happened like that
before I just feel like it makes sense
it makes sense though based on how
events played out I'm like of course I
see you took my advice on the one though
yeah yeah yeah which which I think I
think is a good idea because most people
aren't going to know who this person is
like by now yeah well so when you see
the photo you'll yeah you'll know yeah
you'll know the photo but you won't know
the name right and you'll know the
incident like you'll it because and
really it's the photo of the officer
that is so famous and so it it gives it
really I mean as bad as the Insurrection
was right and and um we'll get into this
more but the photo of the officer
um standing there in the hallway and
everyone probably knows what I'm talking
about officer Goodman he's standing in
the hallway and he's got just this horde
of [ __ ] Maga Trump supporters who
want to overthrow our democracy
and he's the the one officer standing in
between them overthrowing our
constitution
and not it's it's a it's an amazing
image
um and it'll be burned in our minds in
history for a long long time of
of his here his heroic Act of standing
there and with one with his hand like
he's stopping them with his hand
but also at one point was drawn like he
was the one who was like all right
follow me yeah well I mean he and and
um again in that image there's so much
context right right and I I and I think
we'll give that context
um during bonehead
um during that part of it because I
think there's a lot of context there and
I think there's uh it's a great it's a
great
he's a hero he's a real American hero
and I'm not Gabe Sanchez I'm not usually
a fan of police officers and they're
just not I did a here's the thing I did
a sketch uh not too long after the
Insurrection and it was because there
were reports of Capitol Police who were
actually like taking pictures yeah you
know yeah right yeah yeah the whole
thing so I know I mean we have a problem
in this country with uh
um you know law enforcement kind of
being on the side of fascist if you can
imagine oh yeah no it's crazy but what
what happened what is funny is because
every time I hear the name Goodman I'm
always like oh that's right like I
completely forgot when I made this video
it was a SketchUp with this police saw
or this Capital police and he's like oh
yeah let's take a photo and oh you got
to go down there and you got you know
like the the gift shops around the
corner whatever
and the name I came up with at the time
was a I think it's a bad man like the
last name is bad man right or badmin and
you didn't and you didn't and I didn't
know I mean maybe it was subconscious
but I didn't know at the time when I was
like oh I'm gonna make it so it's clear
like this guy isn't any specific person
he's just a representation uh just it's
just generic just generic but I was like
a a DOT Batman right
and I put the video out and be like oh
this is funny this is great whatever but
then I started getting these comments
where people were like oh oh that's
really clever Goodman bad man I was like
wait what like I didn't even I didn't
even register that when I made it but
we've talked about it so many times Gabe
Sanchez where really honestly they are
the parody and the satire of themselves
so it only makes sense when when someone
who just happens to have the name
Goodman right
is the good guy right in the story and
and when you choose to be very obvious
about what you're trying to say about
the police officers that would help the
insurrectionist and would be part
of a coup
when you call him bad man I mean it just
it's the parody is and the satire they
just can't escape it because they are
they embody it I mean look what happened
this week with the [ __ ] trading cards
holy [ __ ] like you can't get any more
cell parity and self-satire oh my God it
is insanity even and I hope we can look
at it the one with the Mount Rushmore
what the [ __ ] oh my God I mean we can go
yeah I I went back to the website last
night because I was trying to figure out
what the quantity was and we're like did
they ever say a quantity and then of
course it was 45
000 and we can get into this did you
figure out because um we read a hundred
but I think it was a hundred was the max
100 was the magic so they yeah they were
like you could buy one ten twenty or a
hundred but the also the 100 was limited
to uh one per person for household
for the sweepstakes that you had to
manually enter but that wasn't a limit
on how many you could buy no no no so
literally and someone was some [ __ ]
stupid hater was in the comments here
earlier and I don't know who it was it
was probably Dave Paddock over on
[ __ ] Facebook he's now our fake Gabe
I guess
um but they were saying that oh hahaha
they sold 45 000. hey dude I hate to
disappoint you you dummy but there was
one person who probably [ __ ] bought a
shitload of them and it's probably
Donald Trump I don't know if you
remember the Melania Trump nft [ __ ]
thing but they had to buy they they
personally had to buy her nfts because
no one would which is pretty funny and
on brand for it right for a a family
that's like hey I just released this
product right and it's a book you have
the RNC spend a hundred plus thousand
dollars to buy a book so that Donald
Trump Jr can get on the [ __ ] New York
best New York Times bestseller list or
whatever the [ __ ] it is well I mean they
do that all the time yeah I know exactly
right but it just shows like I mean you
look at the [ __ ] Donald Trump
Foundation right or the Trump Foundation
right they're buying up things they're
like wait didn't you purchase that thing
but now it's hanging on the wall over
there you know when you're private in
your private yeah this is it because
what they've what they found is that
nobody in their right mind or at least
not the majority of people in their
right mind would actually buy this
[ __ ] Griff so then they have to say
great okay the whole plan here was how
do we I don't know money launder you
know or something along those lines
where it's like because the other thing
too is like you sent me a tweet
yesterday where somebody was like oh
surprise surprise no one knows how the
[ __ ] to control their wallet because you
enter the email and then their credit
card and then yeah nobody has any
because here's the thing these people
don't most likely
you know this that could not be it could
be by Design but more likely it's just
they're inept oh yeah yeah they're
interesting nobody nobody ever on that
team was like hey wait what if these
people don't know how to like open up a
digital wallet and they're like
nobody ever thought like [ __ ] maybe we
should do some user testing they're
someone in that room's probably like
well do we have their money once they
don't know how to open it well yeah so
like what a week here yeah but we give a
[ __ ] if we already got their money what
do we get we done grifted what do we
just send them an email saying 10 times
the the the grip and yeah and the impact
give the impact of a thousand and
they'll give us more money who cares
about the wallet
it's there and I don't want to I don't
want to go in too much because I know
that yeah we're gonna get into this so
yeah we're gonna get the um yeah well
you know what let's let's just do this
because I've got all the assets all
right good to go so let's do this
everyone stick around right after this
break because you're gonna find out who
is because it it was a little we're not
sure it was a little unsure with the
platforms because you know we post a
poll on on Twitter and we post on
YouTube so we were kind of unsure what
would happen yeah I'll talk about it
once we get into it because the
different
um the difference in where you voted and
how you felt you know it maybe it's kind
of like different voting districts
almost different counties exposure you
know top of mind on that platform
exactly so we'll get into this right
after these messages stick around bone
end of the week is next
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
Friday the second hour of the Tony
Michaels podcast you know what that
means bonehead of the week
[Music]
of the week
me and the famous and Gabe Sanchez break
it down on bonehead of the week
Gabe Sanchez we have reached Friday
how do you feel I mean this is a crazy
week huh this week has gone by so
quickly I mean even when we were talking
about like who's gonna be on the
bonehead this week it was like
did that event happen this year yeah
because we were trying to figure out who
you wanted to put on well you had to
you're like yeah these two and then
you're like who else and I'm like I
don't know and I just kind of floating
some ideas and I was like hey what about
Vicki Hartzler you know she went on the
floor and she was crying because you
know she's she she's scared of gay
marriage she's terrified of it you just
cry and I was like nope that was last
week yeah
it just all Blends in I'm just I'm
trying to understand the
just I just I'm trying to understand
time these days you know like now
basically it gets away from you right
basically my my
uh
uh my reference of time is it started
with Elon getting booed on stage there
was videos of that
so that's like the beginning of time
that's the beginning of the week and
then now we've come to the end of the
week and people are still like people it
started with people laughing at Elon and
booing at him at the chase Center in SF
and then it's pretty much ended with
people laughing at Elon because he ran
away from a Twitter space that we were
in last night
um which was hilarious based on all the
other things that were going on
I got some messages here sorry I'm
getting messages oh no don't mind me oh
your here's the thing I'm getting
messages here or someone's trying to
call me about the January 6th select
committee like I was saying on Monday
um
um can that certain someone text her
that's how they're doing yeah well I'm
texting them saying I'm we're lying
we're live on air we're live
um when we're when we're when we're off
here's a question is my screen
flickering right now it is it is
flickering so is it your light
let's see here I'll bring you up look
it's still doing it look it's still
doing it yeah what's going on you're
blinking over there hold on and let me
show this let me try this light look at
this look at this gay that's cool come
on man trying to start
let me go out lingering no my lights
aren't oh you're gonna You're Gonna
Leave the broadcast and then come back
in yeah yeah
get the hell out of here
so as we wait for Gabe Sanchez to come
back because his lights flickering I
want to remind you again
why we're here Monday we're going to
have a hearing and again I was just
getting some phone calls about what that
hearing is going to be so um hopefully
we'll have announcements um and we will
we will give you the link probably this
afternoon we'll develop that link uh on
the Midas touch Network we're also
broadcasted here on the Tony Michaels
podcast so you can watch here on our
Channel
or you can watch over on minus touch
Network because we will start the
coverage uh at our normal show time noon
Eastern as when we'll start the coverage
of the unless they change the time but
as of now the hearing starts at one
Eastern we'll start an hour before did
you get it figured out there we'll start
an hour before and you're not blinking
anymore let's see
nope it doesn't at this point you're
blink free okay all right there's no
strobe no strobe lights over there all
right so I was telling the audience so
on Monday
um if the time hasn't changed and maybe
that's what the phone call is at the
time Jamie I don't know I I just you
know and someone's calling me was going
to give me some updates today about the
hearing so hopefully we'll know like
exactly what they're going to do he gave
Sanchez okay the timing on it but we are
going to broadcast an hour before the
hearing starts it's supposed to start at
uh one Eastern so we'll start at noon
Eastern hour normal time here on the
podcast so we will the podcast will be
the hearing coverage that will be the
podcast so we will do an hour before we
will watch the hearing whatever
they do in the hearing our understanding
is that they're going to present the
refer criminal referrals and then vote
on the criminal referrals and I would
imagine uh Gabe Sanchez as soon as they
vote on the criminal referrals Benny
Thompson Will gavel out
um that is my suspicion because anytime
they've done the referrals before for
the contempt charges that's basically it
that's why I I actually my expectation
is lower than what others I've talked to
um I think it's going to be very abrupt
I actually do not think the hearing is
going to last more than 20 30 minutes
but that's but I'm I'm waiting to hear
in and out make it quick you're blinking
again oh my God what the hell what the
hell are you doing I don't know I
haven't done anything
did you pay your electric bill or they
yeah let's see hold on I'm gonna go out
again yeah okay all right see
ah technical issues technical issues and
see the thing is audience I don't know
if you know this but and Gabe Sanchez is
very picky about details if you've ever
watched any of his videos he's got all
the details in there
um sometimes he'll send me stuff and
he's like you think people will notice
I'm like dude No One's Gonna notice that
no one is going to notice that my new
detail
and he's like oh someone's gonna notice
someone's gonna know is someone gonna
they're gonna know they're not gonna
know yeah they're gonna know
I don't know is that how that goes and
I'm not sure how that tick tock goes I
don't know anyways the point is this
is that he's he's very he's very
particular about details
um so it's not surprising that he does
not want to be on a live stream here
with what looks like his light is
flickering it's probably his camera I
probably should have told him that
something in this cameras lights or
something is is not jiving uh on his
broadcast but anyways Monday my
expectation is and was until I hear
different that it'll be abrupt I don't
know that it'll last longer than 30
minutes I actually believe Benny
Thompson will come in they've already
presented the evidence in the other
hearings my my suspension my suspicion
is Benny Thompson will come in and he'll
gamble in he'll give the reason why
we're there he'll probably let Liz
Cheney definitely present the criminal
referral for Donald Trump I would
imagine that's what's gonna happen that
Liz Cheney is the one that will actually
put in the record
the referral criminal referral for
Donald Trump whatever those criminal
referrals are whether it's you know
seditious conspiracy or obstructing an
official proceeding or whoa whatever
whatever their referrals are going to be
um with the evidence that they've
gathered they've got a lot of evidence
they're likely to have a lot of
referrals
but I would suspect Liz Cheney is going
to give the referral for Donald Trump
and then what they'll do is once they
get that set of referrals on the record
they will vote for those referrals to go
to the doj at well they'll go to the
floor to be voted to go to the doj just
like they did the the contempt referrals
it's going to work almost the exact same
way as the contempt referrals that's how
our referral works we watched it happen
with Steve Bannon Mark Meadows Pierre
Navarro
um so that's what will transpire
on Monday that's my assumption
uh Benny Thompson's really consistent
very I I didn't know much about Benny
Thompson until he became the chair of
the select committee I've got to know
him by covering the January 6 select
hearings he is a no-nonsense person
um he he is he does he is not
for a lot of fluff he is not for a lot
of Pomp and Circumstance he wants to get
right to the point as a chairman
um I think that's why they took such a
painstaking measures to make sure that
the select hearings were so well
produced and that the information was
presented to the American people in a
certain way so there wasn't any BS
there's not something that Benny
Thompson puts up with so I I think it
would I my guess is unless I hear
different
unless I hear different
I think the hearing will be very
straightforward
on Monday but I expect that we are going
to get
um dozens of criminal referrals for
maybe maybe handfuls
of people who were involved in the
Cheeto dust kangaroo coup
so make sure make sure you uh you'll be
looking out for that link on the Midas
touch Network and go follow the minus
touch Network
um for that Monday hearing we will
broadcast from their Channel as well as
ours so don't forget to subscribe here
on the Tony Michaels podcast you're not
going to want to miss the hearing on
Monday
and then Wednesday is when they release
the final report
some were suspecting there might be a
hearing to release the final report but
I that is not my understanding that they
do not need a hearing to release the
vinyl report they can just
release it and I think that's what
they're going to do on Wednesday and the
the reason why they're hurrying here is
because they have this CR problem which
I think and they're going to get the I
think they're going to kick the can in
the next week today possibly for the
continuing resolution if it's not
already happened I don't know maybe
someone can update me on that
um
but they're going to try to get the
continuing resolution done before the
new Congress so that they can actually
divert a government shutdown till
September
because that's what they'll do is
they'll do a continuing resolution until
September
now on their right before that break and
they always they always Kick the Can
right before they break
and the reason why is because
Republicans are piles of [ __ ]
and you have to really get them in a
situation where they don't want to go
back to their District on a break and
have to explain to their constituents
why they shut down the [ __ ]
government
that's that's literally the [ __ ]
strategy that we have is we have to
divert and a a manufactured crisis from
a bunch of America First Nazis
by making sure that a CR is placed in a
certain strategic spot to where they
don't want to behold accountable
do you follow me there so here's the
thing
the government the government decides
how much money we're going to spend and
it's us
we vote on Congress Our House of
Representatives and they appropriate
funds that's the government us
when they appropriate funds when they
pass bills they're spending that money
okay they spend that money
that's the money that's being spent
the Executive Branch the president
United States is the one who
writes up checks
now we have a debt ceiling of so much
debt that we can go into right they
invented this stupid thing
debt ceiling is dumb it's ridiculous
all it is is what we're going to go
through with this condensing resolution
is just just to [ __ ] just to [ __ ]
have something to argue over just to
have a manufactured crisis
so that Fox News can act like the
government's going in the tank because
they're spending too much money and dumb
[ __ ] like that and the Biden
Administration is spending us into
Oblivion the no Administration spends us
into Oblivion none of them
it's not how our government works
Congress the House of Representative
Representatives appropriate funds
they're the ones who vote to spend on
the credit card okay
they use the credit card
the administration whoever it is whoever
the president is
pays the credit card bill got it
I mean just try to put it in simple
terms
where boneheads will understand
if you don't know how our government
works as far as money Congress
appropriates funds
the executive the president the
administration whoever it is
pays the credit card bill got it that's
how it works
and they use this as a negotiating point
to shut down the government they call it
a government shutdown but it's not
really a government shutdown what
they're doing is they're shutting down
the flow of money
and that has wide effects
on the country
in a lot of different places
one of the ones that is a very very hard
uh
one for them to divert and spend their
narrative as the military because you
know they love the military and blah
blah blah support our veterans support
our troops which they don't give a [ __ ]
about veterans or troops Republicans do
not give a [ __ ] about anyone but
themselves
that's it they do not give a [ __ ] about
veterans they do not give a [ __ ] about
our troops I don't know if you remember
uh the [ __ ] we that Jon Stewart went
through during the summer to try to wave
his hands up and down to try to get
politicians to do the easiest thing in
the world which is past The Pact act
they just didn't want to give Biden a
win is what happened and it took its
Insanity that we had to have a very
famous person like Jon Stewart stand
outside the capitol
and yell and scream at these people
obscenities at these people to get them
to do their [ __ ] jobs but it worked
and got it done
but they Republicans do not like
veterans they do not respect our troops
you know we give a [ __ ] about them I
don't give a [ __ ] about you
they don't care about anyone but
themselves but they use the CR in this
way right they shut down the government
and you remember uh in 2018 Trump shut
down the government for all over a month
and it costs it costs the Republicans it
costs them
because they're the ones who always want
to [ __ ] stymie government because
they think government bad government us
dummies government us
government isn't big government isn't
small government is us we are the
government in this democracy now we have
to vote for representatives to vote for
us
but it's us
and if you vote for really shitty
Representatives you're gonna get really
really shitty results
it's kind of the challenge that we're in
right now where in the hell is Gabe
Sanchez I'm still waiting on him that's
why I'm just talking he knows I can talk
for hours
he knows I can talk for hours so he's
not where are you
might have had to restart
like reboot his computer
it's a possibility
you know what when he comes on I should
make him have to sit here and talk to
you
for a few minutes on his own you think
kind of go through my phone send me the
link oh Jesus Christ this guy
this guy
oh he totally he totally he's got uh
computer problems it must be and here's
the here's the link there
he's having all sorts of trouble I'm
guessing he's going to set up his camera
for the um uh for the link which you can
do on our software that's how we like
Rachel we took offer that's how she
joins the show that's how almost all
people join the show say join it with
their cell phone oh or or like on
computer
so as we bring back uh Gabe Sanchez here
as we get him back on the show
what was I talking about oh the
continuing resolution
so they'll they'll get the uh the
continuing resolution until September of
next year and then that is when we'll
have a government shutdown
likely probably for a couple days maybe
a week or two
they're definitely shut down the
government
and the reason why they'll shut down the
government is because Trump is going to
want them to shut down the government
that's why just watch and just yeah um
put a mark in it at 12 33 well 133
Eastern
on December 16th Tony Michaels said the
reason why the Republicans will shut
down the government is because Trump
wants them to
you'll be [ __ ] posting about it he
ain't gonna be in jail by then he'll be
indicted probably by then Jack Smith is
working on that so is the um
the grand jury
and maybe but he won't he won't be
convicted and jailed
he'll still be out running around trying
to commit soft Coos where in the hell is
obvious see this is how it works
there's no dead air on the Tony Michaels
podcast no dead air
um
oh the other the other announcement I
want to make while we're waiting for
Gabe Sanchez's difficulties here his
technical difficulties is
um a Christmas break let me look at the
um the calendar here let's see
um so Christmas is uh next week
and we will be off air the 23rd and the
26th
so uh next week Friday
and the week after that on Monday we
will have a four day weekend so what
we'll do is we will not unfortunately
because it's the holiday we're gonna
we're gonna take a little bit of time
for a weekend
um we will and we will not have a
bonehead of the week next week kind of
like we did with Thanksgiving
um but we we will on the other hand
have one on New Year's because we are
going to take another day off on Monday
the 2nd
so Monday the second will be another day
that we won't have a show
um so the 23rd and the 26th that weekend
of Christmas will be a four day uh
weekend for us here at the Tony Michaels
podcast and then the New Year's
um Monday the 2nd we will not have an
episode that day will not be live on the
air that Monday
and then we'll probably won't take
another day until
um the Fourth of July next year
we'll do every single weekday Monday
through Friday
so next week we will not have a a
broadcast of bonehead we'll do a poll
uh like we've done we'll do a poll for
next week
um like we did on Thanksgiving and
there'll be a winner but we won't have a
a show to do it on so next Friday we'll
be off in the Monday after that so the
23rd and the 26th will take a four day
weekend for Christmas and then we'll
take a three day weekend uh for New
Year's so we'll take the Monday off so
we will have a bonehead that week
on the 30th
I'm looking at the calendar right so
marketing your calendar so if you if you
notice that we have a four day weekend
around Christmas and a three-day weekend
around New Year's it's not because we're
trying to get out of something and we're
just we're just taking some some some
time off well-deserved time off for the
mods too again give the moderators they
did a great job this year as we're
heading into the end of the year they
did a fantastic job moderators work hard
now they don't just show up
um here during the show they keep in
touch with us with us all the time
they're constantly keeping keeping me on
track to be quite honest making sure I'm
seeing things sometimes they send me
stuff say hey don't
um make sure make sure
do
we know Gabe Sanchez wait no Gabe
Sanchez
bonehead of the week
oh let's see
let's go back to the Tweety tweets and
trendy Trends while we're waiting on uh
Sanchez here
now what's going on here
Gabe Sanchez having technical
difficulties during the bonehead of the
week never had too many difficulties
uh during bone end of the week
did you guys know Barbie's trending is
there a movie
is there a Barbie movie
what is this
yeah Barbie the movie
look here Barbie the movie
okay
Warner Brothers he's got Barbie the
movie it's trending and let's see what
else is what else is trending out there
on this
[ __ ] box that is Twitter now
um
thanks for sticking around with us
through the technical difficulties on
bonehead of the week and we're going to
try to do a full bonehead here
um but I'm I'm definitely going to have
to take some sort of a Break
um when Gabe Sanchez gets back on
to uh because we're probably gonna go to
two and a half hours here today uh to
get bonehead in
um
but bonehead is kind of Gabe Sanchez's
thing do you guys know that did you guys
know
that
it bone of the week came from the mind
of Gabe Sanchez so we were trying to
figure out we used to do just one show a
week
do you guys remember that we just did
Wednesday
and we we had a we always had an
interview on a guest on
um but then we switched to our format
that we have now
where we come live every single weekday
for two full hours Monday through Friday
and we had a weekend show called
bonehead of the week because Gabe's like
ah we need something on the weekend a
small show that we can do
and he had this idea to to do a poll and
to interact and engage with you guys
and I was and and he had brought up um a
bit he wanted to do a bit around
bonehead because I I used the word
boneheads a lot
I used it a lot in my videos I use it
right here on the show and he kind of
caught on to the bonehead thing
so he wanted to do something around
bunin Amanda's always pushing for three
hours
[Laughter]
Amanda's like three hours we might go
three hours a day depends on
um Gabe Sanchez technical difficulties
here if he gets back on
we'll see I haven't heard from him yet
he's having a lot of trouble over there
I guess but Amanda's saying three hours
but the bone of the week was on the
weekend that's why I still post the
bonehead of the week on the um directory
I post the bone and a week on the
directory on Sundays because of that
because it was a weekend thing
originally
anyways
oh how well God damn
it's about time you join us so what
would you have to do I'm I'm literally
on my phone right now here uh
hold on so you're on your on your phone
and the microphone on the phone that's
and and the microphone on the phone no
no I'm on the I'm
I'm hearing good no you're still on
you're you're not using that gosh
worthless this guy's worthless this guy
what happened is it your camera that's
doing it that's are we picking up
something I could I can hear you but I
can't hear you on that mic uh do you
have it on yeah
it's just that it's just the phone
microphone is that what everyone else is
here and that's what I'm hearing all
right well either way this is the way
it's gonna be this is the way it's gonna
be here let me here's what you're going
to do
um so
um while you're sitting here because
we're gonna have to go to like two and a
half hours now but I have to take a
break
for for and I had to sit and tell
everyone I can you imagine that me being
in a pinch to talk that I couldn't
figure out something I can't imagine
what that's like no I I it's almost like
I could not do that but here's what I'm
gonna do I'm Gonna Leave This to you I'm
Gonna Leave This to you for a second so
you need to pick out a topic and you
just need to I don't know rant I can't a
minute and a half two minutes whatever
you want to talk about you know what
talk about what you because I actually
predicted what I think the hearing is
going to be on Monday so do that tell
the audience what you think's gonna
happen on the hearing on Monday I'm I've
got to go check on something really fast
oh and then I'll be I'll be back so
everyone here's Gabe Sanchez's opinion
on the um the select meeting on Monday
hey everyone uh I can't see I just want
to put this out I cannot see anything
you guys say right now
um
I just I'm not on my computer but anyway
I think that what we're gonna see is
more or less a recap
um I think Tony said it was gonna be
like 20 30 minutes I don't know exactly
the length but I do think that there's
no New Revelations that are gonna come
out of it maybe they they might kind of
sprinkle in a couple new things I mean
we do have those text messages that were
made public about Mark Meadows so that
is a possibility but that's not to say
that they didn't already know those
things
um
uh they could re-emphasize them but I
think more or less it's just going to be
a quick kind of recap and they're going
to do kind of what they did the LA on
the last hearing which is they uh they
you know voted on a subpoena
um for Donald Trump to show up and so
the only difference now would be that it
would be the criminal referral so I
don't know anything that we will know
that's new necessarily but I think it
will be a nice kind of like you know in
the last episode of the January 6th
hearings we covered this because it's
been a minute um the last one that we
had was
in the middle of October so that kind of
feels like a a lifetime ago especially
as we were talking earlier today you
know we started the week with Elon
getting booed on stage and kind of ended
the week with people laughing at him
crying away and running away from the
Twitter spaces last night so
um
but anyway uh yeah so I think those
that's more or less going to be the
theme
um
recap with maybe a couple new things
sprinkled in just to keep the
conversation going because I think also
the idea you gotta remember
the the mindset that they have right now
they're a group of people that are
leaving you've got uh Liz Cheney uh Adam
Kinder they're both leaving you've got a
committee that will probably not exist
anymore because Republicans have control
of the house as they struggle for
whoever is going to be their leadership
but I do think they've made this up
until the last moment they've really
pushed this hearing to be right before
everyone goes on break right before
everyone goes home with with to their
families for the holidays it's something
that's the last thing that's in your
mind that's a huge kind of cultural
moment that's now in the Lexicon of what
the [ __ ] happened over the last couple
years and so I do think they've they've
you know taken that the producer who
works on it right now you know taking
that producer approach be like we don't
want you to lose interest before you
leave for the next like month or so for
holidays and whatnot so we want to put
this little nugget in there to remind
you exactly what's at stake and exactly
what this committee sought to to find
out
um so
um so speaking of nuggets
Scott here on Facebook said Tony must
have had a what wet wet fart in a white
thong no no that wasn't the moment that
I had
um it was just simply a break nature
called had to drain the radiator before
we start the Monet of the week see
that's the problem with three hours is
Gabe Sanchez can probably sit through
three hours without that having to take
a piss but I drink way too much coffee
the [ __ ] for three hours if you don't
drink coffee you know you have the
occasional bubbly water then you're good
to go oh God damn he with the soda
stream you went to SodaStream
um so everybody we're gonna looks like
we're gonna go close to three hours but
let's do this let's start bonehead of
the week
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to this week's edition of
bonehead of the week with my co-host
Gabe Sanchez and his all his technical
difficulties this week you know what I
just realized you're not going to be
able to send me any links I'm gonna have
to do this all on my own you're just
sitting there looking pretty giving us
commentary to the cell phone but it
honestly I'm gonna have to go off memory
here of the things that I've watched
this week unless you could pull them up
but I'm gonna have to go on well I'll
pull I'll be able to pull these things
up okay be able to pull these things up
it's gonna happen and I'm fresh I'm
ready to go I've got at least another
hour and a half with me before we start
I just want to make sure are people
hearing like can they double hear what's
going on here no huh no okay I just want
to make sure that like because it's
coming out of the phone no no I have no
I have no Echo because you got the echo
control on it as long as I don't yell
and scream yeah we should be good okay I
mean it may be a problem when I yell and
scream them I mean you'll have to tell
me what the audio
sounds good
[Music]
good go good to go for bonehead of the
week you know every single week
you vote you decide for bonehead of the
week and you can vote on our YouTube
channel the Tony Michaels podcast
subscribe there go to the community tab
you can vote for bonehead of the week
every single week and as long as Twitter
still exists
which we're going to talk about on Bonet
today you go to at Tony Michael's POD at
Tony Michael's pod you can vote there on
Twitter while that pile of garbage is
still around and you know we do this
every single Friday here on the Joni
Michaels podcast we also put a little
clip of bone of the week over the minus
touch networks if you're over there now
subscribe to the minus touch Network
okay Gabe Sanchez we've got these
boneheads it was pretty clear on these
first two right but we had trouble
yeah finding the last one but you know
what bonehead's gonna bonehead and Ron
DeSantis presented a very good
opportunity for this week even though it
wasn't in the news that that much and
there's reasons why so let's start there
let's start with Ron DeSantis why did we
put Ronda Santos with Elon Musk and
Donald Trump on this week's bone end of
the week what was what was the main
reason I know the story here but while I
find it
um because Rhonda Sanders does a lot of
bone-headed [ __ ] but there was one thing
specifically it was the it was vaccine
related wasn't it yes yes it was so
Rhonda sampus
um you know he's been all over the map
as most of these [ __ ] ridiculous
Liars are there are a bunch of America
First Nazis so they're complete Liars
now but this here Christopher Webb
um you know he's a he's a friend of the
show here he puts a lot of great tweets
if you're not following Chris go follow
him but he's got a video here of Rhonda
Santos first run to Santas
and he says Governor Ron DeSantis is
lying again about coveted vaccines and
more folks will die because of his
ridiculous political play his base
before and after he was an anti-vaxx
Governor now you got to remember Rhonda
Santa's has had a lot of difficulty
managing the pandemic in his State
because not only is he trying to not
kill people because he wants to have
those votes of people that he doesn't
kill but he also has to placate to the
base the tail that Wags the dog you know
he has to really he has to really get
manga excited about him right yeah
that's the position that a lot of the
you know even when you look back at what
happened in the last two weeks around
Kanye and Nick Fuentes and Alex Jones
and all this stuff like it's the same
thing right you know even with internal
struggles in the RNC and and the
Republican Party being like ah we should
say something or you shouldn't say that
or like oh that's too far on the
anti-Semitism but some of it's fine
that's the same thing here is is they
struggle to actually pick a pick a lane
or pick a position in a sense like this
is bad and the person who said this is
bad right uh instead of doing that they
say well this is bad and that's it and
the same way here is you've got Ron
DeSantis uh you know trying to
Dart in between both lanes and be like
well I said you know saying one thing
but not totally going as far as he
should or still trying to keep that base
in mind in the event that he does decide
to run to the next I don't know well and
that's I think what he's up against here
and he has he has to out Maga the Maga
King right so he's got he's got an out
manga the Cheeto dust q anoner and
that's what he was that's what he's been
doing and that's what he did the other
day this was December 13th
um and it's really weird like this I
don't think this video shows it really
well
um there's other videos out there but
there's clips and and I I'm guessing
he's in front of a green screen
um and then he's projected behind him
it's like almost like uh supposed to be
a zoom meeting it feels like but it
really does give this ominous like
tutorial type when I saw that I thought
at first he was honest set and those
were mod like it felt like you're in a
newsroom and you've in the control room
and you've got all the monitors for all
the different programs on that's
it was it is very like dictator like
where you're seeing this one dude and
then there's a bunch of people are
looking about it's
it kind of reminds me of uh of like the
I forget his name but the evil guy that
was in like V for Vendetta the dictator
in that one where he's like in front you
know there's a big crowd of people but
then there's a huge monitor in the back
it just like he I think they had like a
nightly program that was like just a
bunch of fascist type of programming you
know the other the other movie that it
kind of reminds me of now that I'm
thinking about you're bringing up movies
you ever seen 12 Monkeys when when it's
in the future and they have like the
council and they have all the the TVs
and stuff boy it really does and and
because he's talking about viruses here
but let's listen to this um this mashup
of Ron DeSantis versus Ron DeSantis on
the coveted vaccine today I'm announcing
uh a petition with the Supreme Court of
Florida to in panel a Statewide grand
jury to investigate any and all
wrongdoing in Florida with respect to
covid-19 vaccines and that will come
with legal processes that will be able
to get more information and to bring
legal accountability for those who
committed misconduct if you are
vaccinated fully vaccinated the chance
of you getting seriously ill or dying
from covid is effectively zero if you
look at the people that are being
admitted to hospitals uh over 95 percent
of them are either not fully vaccinated
or not vaccinated at all and so these
vaccines are saving lives they are
reducing mortality okay so there's
Rhonda Santa's first Ronda Sanchez a
couple things and I know you've probably
got comments and I want to see what your
comment is because I'll back it up so
you can see this that what we were
talking about the imagery yeah
but to the second statement first that
was July 21st 2021 and um Rhonda Santos
was desperately trying to get Floridians
to take the vaccine at that point is
because he was desperately trying to get
his death rate in a position where he
was not the he was not a [ __ ]
derelict well you don't want to be you
know you don't want to be last second to
last is totally fine right so if you're
second to like if you're the second
worst right stay with debts then that's
okay but you you don't want to be the
worst state with this especially if
you're going to run for president so he
was desperately trying to get people to
get vaccinated because he knew the truth
now fast forward to just this week
December 13th where he's going he's
going to um have a
um an investigation of himself
apparently because he was pushing the
vaccines really [ __ ] kind of weird it
almost seems like it's [ __ ] to me ah
I couldn't imagine I couldn't imagine
Ron DeSantis saying a bunch of [ __ ]
but I'm sure it's a bunch of [ __ ]
but yeah now we now what he's doing is
he is again preparing to run for
president but now it's a different
reason in 21 it was I don't want to be
last I I desperately want to make sure
that I don't look like I'm a dumb [ __ ]
that killed off hundreds of thousands of
Floridians because I can't say the thing
that needs to be said into a microphone
go get vaccinated it [ __ ] works now
fast forward December 13th now what he
wants to do is investigate because now
he's got to run for election where we
still have people even after all this
time after all the [ __ ] we've been
through with this pandemic all that our
country collectively has learned about
viruses in general
not just about code but in general about
sickness vaccines and how they work and
what this stuff is I mean we were all
forced to be educated on this stuff yeah
and here he is placating to the base
um because he wants his image to be that
he is more anti-backs than Trump and
that is the important distinction here
is Rhonda Santos is trying to set
himself up where he can have a battle
with Trump and win that battle inside of
Maga
um so let me go to
the imagery here there's the there it is
now you see Ronda Santos is here this is
really [ __ ] weird games yeah I don't
know if this is a green screen this is
this might be an actual like are you
[ __ ] serious it feels I mean I don't
know it looks like he's at a table right
because he's got he's got his um this is
his Surgeon General over here right yeah
yeah yeah and this is like I mean to me
it looks like an actual screen when you
when you look at it like that again it
really does remind me of something from
like V for Vendetta or something that is
like you know we watched a lot of
Russian TV clips
yeah and and I I don't play a lot of
them here because
um for our audio audience I I know I
have a way to translate it in real time
um so you just hear Russian and anyways
the point is is you know I've said this
before the Russian TV like the Russian
broadcast they really do feel like game
show type like Who Wants To Be A
Millionaire type thing this has that
kind of feeling
is trying to you know give off Putin
Vibes here I don't know it's you know
what it also shows because like
typically when you're on on camera you
know if you're at a rally you know you
can position people to be behind you if
you're at a uh like in in the 2021 clip
he's got some people but the cameras you
know tightly shot where it is
like we know that image matters right we
know that he'll he'll berate [ __ ]
kids with masks on because it's their
choice but he doesn't want that image of
uh of people masking up right God forbid
people just like are courteous and and
care for other people's lives but
whatever
uh in this image here you've got these
people I don't know what the positions
are if these are random people in the
government of the State of California of
Florida or what but
it does create a virtual feel of that so
he's there and look at all these people
who are behind him yeah but it looks
very weird it's we don't know it's it's
[ __ ] weird for sure like I don't know
who's for sure I don't know who the
woman is and the guy is or the like
larger screens like I'm assuming they're
in some sort of larger kind of high
repositions but you've got all these
other people
which maybe they're part of the State of
Florida uh government but
it really does give this an idea of it's
projecting this image of I'm Ron
DeSantis and I'm a [ __ ] idiot but
these people are behind me you know and
that's what it really comes down to is
it's all image look at this guy
in in perspective to all these people
he's not alone he's got all these other
anti-vaxxer [ __ ] Trump or idiot
people that are there trying to risk
other people's lives so they can just
not be wrong because remember to be
wrong you'd have to admit that you're
wrong and he doesn't want to do that and
that is the fundamental principle of
trumpism the never admit you're wrong
that way you'll never be wrong that's
right and we talked about that with
Texas Paul right but here I want to
point out something now that I'm
thinking about it
in this image so Rhonda Santos is
sitting here in the middle there's at
least eight foot if not at a bare
minimum six foot between him and his or
general and then it's on a zoom call I'm
presuming so that they don't all have to
be in the same room are you you know
where I'm going with this yeah yeah yeah
no he's literally he's literally like
he's literally like uh the the illegal
act and the thing we need to investigate
is that people Force vaccine on us so we
so that there for whatever reason and
coveted this and covet you know not real
yet they're doing the actual thing that
everyone during the pandemic was
actually doing to make sure that the
virus wasn't spreading around because we
didn't have the vaccines yet yeah so I
don't know if he's like hey we should
just social distance and do this I don't
know what he's doing his man is his
wife's I mean like I
his wife survived like she did she's not
she's no longer going through treatment
right she survived cancer I I can I
cannot confirm nor deny because that's
something
he's that's something where I'd be like
oh he's like cognizant of that right
he's got a wife that either way like it
has a very uh
vulnerable immune system whether she's
still going through treatment or she
finished up treatment you're like you're
still like you just [ __ ] wrecked your
body to fight this cancer so uh I
wouldn't be surprised if you know he's
[ __ ] touting all this [ __ ] but in the
in the back of his mind he's like oh I
can't expose myself to then expose my
wife right
um
so you look at the distance and it's
also funny because that's Surgeon
General he comes I think from Stanford
or out here in California
but the guy's a [ __ ] idiot man the
way he's like I don't believe in the
science I don't believe that distance I
don't believe this is like pushing this
idea that oh you could just go cough on
somebody's face and be totally fine and
vaccines don't work despite the fact
that years and years and years of
experiencing other [ __ ] epidemics
pandemics tree influence but he's he did
the same thing with mask and it's like
look mask you cannot you can like you
know we can go round and round about a
very advanced technology that is the
covet vaccine right we can go around we
can go days right or how the virus was
made if it was made in a Wuhan lab I
mean you can go round and round round
about these things there is one thing
that is finite that you can that is very
hard to dispute and we've talked about a
fart through underwear that Marjorie
Taylor green a mask on your face and it
doesn't matter if it's covered the flu
it doesn't matter like it's not hard
like
during the the uh flu pandemic
um right before 1920 so 1918 right
they understood then yeah you had to put
a [ __ ] piece of cloth over your mouth
so you wanted photos of them at baseball
games right walk outside the newspaper
outside with mask time to be like okay a
hundred years ago even these people
understood that there was a health risk
because the science isn't hard to figure
out on that right again it's it's very
tangible like it the science on mask is
tangible you can see it like you don't
need a microscope you don't need just
um books of data and you don't need High
degrees of Education to understand why
this vaccine technology and how it works
it is it it really is one of the
simplest things to understand and
actually I think it's disappointing that
us have a collective as a country as a
whole didn't actually pull that one
thing out
uh of the pandemic and make it part of
our culture here's what I mean by that
is that
in other parts of the world during flu
season or during outbreaks of even just
the simple flu or a cold they put masks
on to not get sick like it's not
complicated it's not hard but we
couldn't even manage to come out of the
pandemic
um it's a simple example is uh schools
right a lot of elementary schools Junior
highs especially because that's when the
kids start you know getting really close
to each other
um
they start smooching on each other and
stuff
the viruses spread around like crazy in
schools yeah and because the communities
that are surrounded by these schools I
mean obviously the human beings the
children that are in those schools go
back in the community every single day
and they start spreading around to the
rest Community it's like a hub for
viruses yeah how we couldn't figure out
that during an outbreak whatever it is
in a school in a building
of a of a virus whether it be a cold flu
whatever it is
to just say hey if you come in this
building
you gotta have a mask on for the next 10
days for the next 10 days and it's for
no other reason that we have certain
amount of people in here that have been
sick and we don't want you to get sick
how we cannot figure that out as a
collective as a whole is very
disappointing and it shows how broke we
are and it shows how Ronda Santos is
taking advantage of this and really I
want to point something out Rhonda
Santos can absolutely go [ __ ] himself
um so go to
stored.dtonymichaels.com I'm going to
give a pitch here uh store.d Tony
michaels.com grab your Rhonda Santos can
go [ __ ] himself shirt because he
absolutely can [ __ ] all the way off and
as far as I'm concerned so I want to go
back to our concessions here we got a
special special
um little thing here this week that has
never happened on bonehead of the week
Elon Musk was one of our contestants but
he also showed up Gabe Sanchez as the
alpha cook can you explain the rules of
bonehead of the week and how this
happened are you changing the terms of
service all the sudden uh to shoot your
fancy for Elon Musk here this is a is it
a private private little thing we do we
own it we we decide what happens on the
Fly just like Elon Musk and the reason
yeah the reason that um I did this this
week is because
oh so you're the dictator here at the
bonehead of the week yeah yeah who
changes the terms of service as we go
you know it's my baby and so I figured
why not as the God here right oh oh my
God that's uh decide that that Elon Musk
now when we made when we made this
week's poll we're like all right who do
you want to do okay well we're pretty
sure Elon will win of course we have to
put Trump in and we were like uh Ron
DeSantis
but as I was going through this morning
and I was like man who had the most
cuckiest Vibe this week who who had this
whole idea of I'm gonna take my Twitter
and go home right I'm gonna [ __ ]
[ __ ] about the First Amendment Free
Speech all this [ __ ] I'm a free
speech absolutist and then as soon as
somebody starts to call me out on it I
go you're gone you're gone you're gone
that very much feels like an alpha cup
when you don't like what happens and in
a [ __ ] okay here's a perfect example
last night he does a poll because
everyone's like what the [ __ ] why are
you Banning these journalists what
happened to you accepting people of
different opinions right
he goes okay fine he puts out a poll he
says should like what is the length of
time that I should bring back the the
people like unban them right it said now
uh I'm gonna bring I'm gonna bring it up
here yeah so it said now 12 hours seven
days longer or tomorrow seven days
longer okay and this is this is the
accounts that he suspended yesterday the
journalist as they are
um not you know I I actually said in the
beginning of the show that I don't give
a [ __ ] that he banned him and I think I
even messaged that to you because a lot
of people were really upset about
Aaron's account I'm like he can do what
he gives a [ __ ] right it's his what are
you gonna do and you're gonna start
protected inside his platform on his
website
yeah sorry but but I was going to say
that this he's he's he's he's asking
he's crowdsourcing what the terms of
service should be in this moment
literally by saying what should I how
long should I leave them suspended for
and obviously if you know anything about
the Twitter poll of course now was the
winner right and because I'm not sure
how long he put this poll it could have
been more than a couple of hours uh yeah
it was Max because when I when I voted
there was like 11 minutes left and I was
like oh [ __ ] so I think it was only up
for like maybe a couple hours max okay
so what was the result what what did he
so the result was 43 percent of people
said hey we want them to come back now
because [ __ ] so what was it the
result he wanted no so the even though
the people the literally just to quote
him the people have spoken
and then he goes nah you know what no
that's not actually it didn't come out
the way that I wanted so yeah
too many options will redo the poll so
then he did he put out a new poll which
was for is it still four hours yeah yeah
it'll it'll close down tonight okay and
then he trimmed it down to now
or longer or something like that yeah
two options
two God forbid we get too many options
but it's literally the maximum options
possible in a [ __ ] Twitter poll he
says now tomorrow seven days uh
uh longer here's the here's the problem
with elon's logic here if there was any
he says
okay fine I didn't get the results that
I wanted so now I'm going to put up a
new poll he puts up a new poll which you
see right here and it says unsuspend
accounts who dots my location they did
not dox his location in real time so he
can stop that [ __ ] narrative right
now now or in seven days now is winning
I believe that now will win at the end
you've already got three million votes
so he would need many many more Millions
votes to flip the script on this uh
because if anyone knows how stats work
and [ __ ] sample sizes uh he's he's
[ __ ] on this bull too is what you're
saying he's [ __ ] on this because again
it now they say want to un Bannon now so
this morning or last night I guess some
people were saying some stuff and he's
like oh people think uh
uh being suspended equals or like a
suspension does not equal death right
because somebody had tweeted something
he responded to be like oh they're being
so dramatic they're saying that
suspension equals Death or whatever
the thing here is he had previously said
so everyone that got banned had a
permanent suspension that is what their
account said right it was permaband it
was a perma-ban no reason was given they
weren't in in what people call twitmo or
jail and let me let me explain this real
quick because I did this in the first 30
minutes what and it's important what
he's saying in this tweet because he was
dancing around it until this point
because he did a Twitter space which
we'll probably talk about here too in a
second
but he says unsuspend the accounts which
are journalists who doxed my exact
location which is [ __ ] untrue is is
completely in real time here's his
argument he is saying what Elon Musk is
saying is that by someone posting a link
to a website that shows the tracking of
his airplane's tail number his location
is really [ __ ] dumb this is Elon Musk
claiming he is always on his airplane
this is [ __ ] stupid and by the way I
just want to point out because that's
what that's what he's so upset about is
that there is an account called Elon jet
and they track his plane and they do
this for a lot of different um uh people
who have their own planes and Elon Musk
Jeff Bezos Trump they all choose to buy
their own private jet and by choosing to
buy their own private jet and have their
own tail number they can be tracked the
plane can be tracked if you Charter
private jets right if you're chartering
different private jets no one will ever
know exactly what tail number you're
flying under yeah it really doesn't make
any sense that you have to look at the
Manifest right well you'd have to have
access to the Manifest the problem that
Elon Musk has
is that he doesn't understand that he
made a choice to buy a plane and it's
his private plane but that doesn't mean
he doesn't get the tail number to be
private he doesn't fully and that's
really what he's saying is I don't want
you to know anything about me I want to
know everything about you because it's
always for the not me and it's the same
thing here with the suspension and the
free speech talk and all this [ __ ]
because I want to [ __ ] cancel whoever
I want because it's good for me not for
thee and and that really is truly it
because again the whole airplane thing
and then his argument was is that the
some of these journalists were posting
this link to where they could track his
jet which is not against the term of
service by the way that's [ __ ]
um you know you you if if you actually
posted elon's must at personal address
or his phone number that's against terms
of service or or or you started doxing
him in other ways that is against terms
of service I've actually had that happen
no I've had that happen to me according
to Elon
you could reveal certain locations of
people that are after the fact right but
if you were because and then this is
where I have I was thinking about this
the other day when I was I was out for a
walk
let's say that someone reveals you're
where you live right it's it's not your
real-time location right I guess
technically somebody might be able to
find it they look up like in the White
Pages or something like that if your
information is there
but also you could make the argument at
certain locations that you have listed
someone's like oh was that where you
were real time it's like well I lived
there so I'm there all the time how
would you know if I was or was not there
so
like because you could you could you
could argue where he goes oh well
doxiness or like you know revealing this
person's home address isn't docking them
because they weren't there in real time
right you could be like oh I lived there
so I'm there all the time so yeah but
the idea yeah but the idea that that the
only time elon's jet moves is with him
on it is ridiculous I mean that's
ridiculous what people what what what
Elon in in [ __ ]
sax and Jason calacanus and all these
[ __ ] other idiots from the PayPal
crew and that are like are his [ __ ]
bored right now uh because we'll get
into the Twitter spaces in a moment
because I was in there last night when
all this went down
but the thing that I actually you listen
you let now I'm gonna I'm gonna show a
video of it but I was I took my dogs out
for a walk and I was like all right I'm
gonna listen to this thing and was
listening and I heard Jason [ __ ]
[ __ ] and moan and whine about [ __ ] and
I was like shut the [ __ ] up man I
[ __ ] oh God and I have personal [ __ ]
with Jason because Jason was a former
investor of a company that I started
with a few other people in SF
yeah we'll get into another I'm gonna
see if I can get him on the show and uh
oh okay yeah we can discuss this but
anyway
um
so
the idea that Elon Musk is always in the
car is
is asinine or he's always in the is in
the plane is asinine because here's the
thing the kid Jack who made this account
because it's just an automated account
it's pulling in a feed from what the
tail number is and the Elon the Elon jet
account and he's he's made several of
these accounts right right and what
people need to understand is it wasn't
malicious Jack Sweeney what was at least
a fan of Elon Musk he made this because
he believes in the importance if you're
going to talk about carbon emissions and
you're going to be a person who is
pushing forward a company that is
environmentally friendly or like
environmentally friendly and and the
example of Tesla for Ev an example of
Tesla if that you're going to push that
you're going to push you know using
battery over uh gasoline then and this
and and this is not new
you could you know tracking people's
pattern of travel to call them out and
say hey this is a hypocritical claim
that you're trying to do this but then
you're spending this much gasoline and
this is how much this jet is emitting
back into our environment right so it
does seem you know it's it's like when a
bunch of billionaires go to an
environmental conference and they talk
about all these [ __ ] crazy ideas but
then they were they all individually
flew in on a private [ __ ] G5
so this is just another moment where
people need to understand it again jack
made this because he was a fan of Elon
he wasn't just tracking Elon this is one
account he has other accounts he tracks
[ __ ] Bezos uh [ __ ] Bill Gates all
these people
but if you're going to make the claim of
I'm pushing this zero carbon footprint
with this car which is untrue because
energy has to come from somewhere
and you have to produce that energy
if you're gonna fly around in a private
jet and claim zero emissions or you're a
zero emission [ __ ] person
you're gonna get called out for it and
that's no different than other reporters
who have done the same thing for him and
other billionaires to be like we have to
have some accountability in the claims
that you make and the actions that you
take and that's all that that count was
and Elon even said in the beginning or
the middle of November he said uh I have
no problem with this account even though
it tracks my my jet or my plane or
whatever and again he's not in the jet
all the time that plane flies from one
[ __ ] airport to another it flies to
another place to get maintenance it
flies back to that airport right stays
in the hub flies to another one to go
pick them up like people need to
understand he's not chained inside the
jet is what you're saying this thing
will fly with three people minimum
assuming there's like two pilots or One
Pilot in in like a flight attendant or
two flight attendants like there's
always two to three people minimum that
are flying in there that are just
maintaining the plane and taking it from
point A to point B and that's kind of
the whole point about the Elon jet
account is to hold the McCann
accountable for that right but but again
this is a choice that Elon has made to
buy this jet uh there are plenty there
are plenty of Charter services out there
where Elon Musk has enough money and
enough resources he could Charter Jets
whenever he wants like he would not have
to own his own jet he could just Charter
One and there's plenty of people out
there that own a plane that would
Charter it to him
um again it would be less trips for
maintenance less trips for personnel
um to to get repairs all this stuff save
him money too right by the upkeep and
storage of a plane like we already know
like but that's the point though that's
the point though is that this isn't
about the plane it's not about the
location in the plane it's about Elon
Musk gets different rules and Elon Musk
wants different rules for himself and
it's no more apparent than in this space
I couldn't believe this now this is a
Twitter Space Twitter space is it still
down this Twitter space is still build
down from what I understand and I'll
talk about that once we watch yeah I
tried to go into a few this morning when
I heard it was down and it wasn't
allowing me I sent you a screenshot it
wasn't allowing me to get in it just
said it was unavailable on this device I
think is what it said um so I don't know
what he did to turn it off any tweet
that was promoting a space previously
because I was trying to find one
because here's well once we watch this
then you'll understand the comment I'm
about to make right so so this is this
is the not the last Twitter space but to
elon's mind this was the last Twitter
space he would tolerate
um
there's a couple of funny things about
this space number one
you've probably never seen this many
real blue checks in a space like this
yeah
um there was a lot here when I was in
there a lot of them were journalists
right and there was a glitch and that's
what gives them the blue check almost
right exactly but even though that Elon
uh rewrote the code or had someone
rewrite the tooltip text to say
look they may or may not be uh notable
how which city do you have to be because
people don't buy your blue check it is
you now have to throw shade on them
because they earned that blue check
through whatever means experience school
work whatever
um that's a whole nother debate whether
you should be enthused about having a
blue check whether it's a real one or an
eight dollar one that's a whole nother
debate yeah but but the thing is because
there was uh the the Legacy verified
checks there were accounts that were
were that were suspended and you can see
it here on the screen now the Elon jet
was suspended at this moment but they
were in this space so Drew oh yeah
Drew's a tech reporter at Washington
Post so both of these accounts are are
uh but they're in the space but they're
in the space there's a glitch
um which people which people identify
because I was so confused I was like
wait he brought back Elon Jet and Drew's
back and then when she has to have the
space that's what I thought I was like
what the [ __ ] I was like what's going on
and then when I went into their profile
it was like oh permanently suspended
their permaband so basically these
people were more or less talking beyond
the grave is the way that they joked
about it is that they were able to
access the space but they were still not
able to tweet like see any notifications
because there's a there was a uh from
what I remember reading it was um
because the Twitter spaces is based on
Periscope and Periscope is well that's
actually how how we stream to Twitter
still because that's the line Periscope
used to be an outside service and then
they made it internal yep exactly so
they acquired it there was a whole thing
if people remember the uh the joke on
like Silicon Valley of like hot dog not
hot dog because there was a problem with
people exposing themselves on Periscope
so they were trying to identify how to
look out for dicks and [ __ ] the whole
here we are back to dick pics yeah back
to dick pics but that's what happened so
Periscope was a live streaming uh
service that they Acquired and then uh
they brought into Twitter and Periscope
spaces is built on the back of periscope
so
if you're able to access Periscope like
I think it was like if you had a grant
essentially a grandfather to counter you
made it at some point I think I don't
know how many years ago but uh if you
had still if you had access to that then
there was a glitch that you could access
spaces even if you didn't have access to
your account right there's some kind of
there's some kind of Open Door there
because that that's how we stream we use
a tool that uses periscopes to stream
but because now Periscope is actually
internal at Twitter you used to be able
to like comment on Twitter and I could
see it but now it doesn't when Twitter
actually moved it to be internal they
never used they never uh you that tool
doesn't exist anymore yeah where the
comment on Twitter so if you're
commenting on Twitter I don't get to see
it I hear it live on the show because
because when they moved Periscope to be
internal to Twitter that message won't
pull back to me because of the the the
the the the API or whatever it is
um you know maybe I'm yeah the API yeah
the API does not allow does not allow
that message to automatically come back
to me on my screen where I can see it
like YouTube does twitch Facebook I get
to see all those messages in one feed I
don't get to see that on Twitter I
actually have to go into the tweet and
see the feed so if you're commenting on
Twitter and you're wondering why are you
responding to me there because I can't
see it I can't see it because of how
they did this also a result of um
when you acquire companies and
Technology
um you're like all right cool we got to
work in for the most part you know like
we've got it like we can still support
it but the idea that you're like
constantly like sometimes you'll find
that they'll just be like all right
we're just gonna drop support or we're
gonna kill the team that worked on it
and just have people like maintain it
right or or kill the features so they
don't have to maintain certain things
right exactly yeah but now um so this is
the Twitter space that was operational
while Elon was in there and Elon
actually speaks so let's listen to the
back and forth here in the last few
hours with a handful of journalists uh
being bad
uh yeah um well as I'm sure everyone
who's been dachshund uh would agree you
know uh showing real-time information
about somebody's location is
inappropriate and I think everyone on
this call would not like that to be done
put to them and and there's not going to
be any distinction in the future between
journalists civil journalists and and
regular people everyone's going to be
treated the same they're not I want to
stop it there because that's Elon
talking about real-time doxing and
real-time location
someone pointed out I'm not sure who it
was
um at this moment but someone tweeted a
tweet are retweeted or image screenshot
and a tweet of elon's several weeks ago
when he was at the Twitter headquarters
and had all these people in the pictures
which literally is Real Time location
you know where the address is you know
what the building is you could damn near
almost tell what floor they were on you
can almost tell the locations of dozens
of his employees in this one duet so
literally if he believes what he's
saying he should believe that tweet of
his is a violation of terms of which it
is not there's a lot of these moments in
his own tweets where he'll say one thing
and then you'll find out that he's like
oh whoa whoa whoa that's not fair for me
me you know right well it is this is
just one this is a this is a big example
because of how much it's like really
blown up and the the over the overreach
and reaction that he's had on the
platform due to
because here's the the for people who
don't understand this or like or don't
understand kind of what did like how we
got to this moment right here on this
Twitter space
what happened was
Elon the his his jet went from one place
to another right it went uh flew into La
I think
um
and
I guess some person supposedly
showed up jumped down the hood of the
car thinking that Elon was in the the
car right but it turns out his child x a
E12 whatever the [ __ ] it is
um was in the car which is like already
kind of weird because you're like oh
that kid's like a baby who's traveling
like why why is where but was Eon on the
plane Elon was not on the plane what
then how is it his real-time location
exactly so then they were like well
people doxed me and so somebody found
the flight path and they knew where I
was coming in but they thought it was me
but it ends up it was just my kid now I
get if you have children I know Tony
you've gone to this too like you've had
people share stuff about your children
which you're like that's [ __ ] weird
it is weird when you're trying to attack
them but this is so I get you know a
parent's you know innate internal kind
of like I gotta protect my kid for
whatever by whatever means necessary but
also like if you're trying to use the
argument that this person is docking my
own location and they revealed where I
was but I wasn't really there so then
they they went and they jumped on the
hood of the car but I wasn't in the car
it was my kid in the car for their
safety fine now this is where this
started to unravel because he said oh
we've identified who the person is and
we're taking legal action yeah they even
brought up the FBI investigation right
right so now to take legal action like
you probably need a basis like a I don't
know a police report to say this thing
took place because at that point it's
all it's kind of more or less hearsay
it's he said she said they were there no
they weren't you have documentation
whatever but also like do you have
documentation of the crime being
committed that you're claiming and so
reporters like Aaron and other people
were just sharing what they had
discovered they had to go report on this
because it was a story
and the story right they weren't caught
they weren't causing this right
reporting on the jumping on the hood and
the confusion of him not actually always
being in the plane like they were
reporting on what had happened right
thing too it's like you know that even
in the space they're like we and they'll
probably mention this too they're like
we don't do that like we know as
journalists we don't docks people's
location and they're like we didn't even
share the link and he's like yes you did
he's like I did not share that link one
one thing um is for sure if you are a
real journalist I'm not talking about a
[ __ ] uh [ __ ] doxer behind a
[ __ ] uh some sort of [ __ ]
Anonymous account which that's what was
happening to me they were doxing me they
were posting pictures of my children off
another private account they were
pulling and and trying to use that to
get me to do something which [ __ ] you
you obviously do not know who you're
talking to you it's the [ __ ] them guy
you can go [ __ ] yourself but here's the
thing is that
um these journalists are are
credentialed they are public this is
this is not um Anonymous of who these
people were reporting this right
especially because Aaron was just named
media yes uh Journey here so let's see
this on the back of that is so
interesting now I will say I want to say
here that
um the problem with our journalists and
our media right now
is they clearly do not understand
what it means for freedom of speech it's
almost as much as Elon does not it kind
of shows in this call to be quite honest
with you because not only is Elon being
a big [ __ ] baby here about this and
he's changing his terms of service and
he's really destroying a company that he
paid 44 billion dollars over him getting
his feelings hurt which I said before
hey [ __ ] put down the [ __ ] machine
hire back all your [ __ ] employees let
them run that [ __ ] and you go pretend
that you invented electricity or some
[ __ ] just do that and you will be none
of this [ __ ] will happen to you you got
enough money to live out your life and
do whatever the [ __ ] you want at this
point you you're starting to [ __ ] that
up but he just needs to do that but also
in this call the journalist they're
really they're they're really on
misunderstanding the freedom of press
the Press does not have the right to be
on a private website they do not they
can actually report on that website they
can report on Twitter they have the
right to report on Twitter they actually
should do that that is what they should
do report on the facts and let the
American people know how [ __ ] awful
Elon is and and expose him for what he
truly is which is not smart which is not
genius right he's a piece of [ __ ] he's
not self-made he's not an inventor of
anything
he's not smart he's not a genius he's
not this but he is Nazi he is Nazi so
but the journalists here are a little
butt hurt and don't understand that Elon
literally can just get rid of him just
like he can get rid of spaces he he he
could wake up tomorrow Gabe Sanchez and
he could say [ __ ] Twitter I'm turning it
off and he could absolutely turn the
whole thing off and just turn it off
shut the doors shut it off we wouldn't
be able to log in no one would be it's a
Twitter and say uh it'd be a 404 you
know error can't find it sorry it's gone
he could do that that's he owns it now
but they don't clearly understand in a
call but he is a big [ __ ] man baby
and this is ridiculous but let's let's
listen to a little more of his tantrum
here how special because you're
returnless there's you're just you're
you're a quitter you're a citizen okay
so again he says um and I'm sorry to
stop it so abruptly again but he said
yeah you're not special because you're a
journalist now that is is untrue that is
again Elon not understanding the freedom
of press right he doesn't understand
that a credentialed member of the press
is different than someone else doxing
someone it is completely different they
it is different no matter what you want
to say how you want to spend it what the
[ __ ] you want to do if your credentialed
with a real news Outlet not some [ __ ]
fake ass right-wing website or some
Trader TV News Network I'm talking about
real journalism someone who cares about
facts who's going to fact check who's
going to make sure the other side that
they're reporting on gets a chance to to
look at those facts that they're going
to report on that's [ __ ] journalism
it is different it is in our [ __ ]
Constitution you pile of [ __ ] Elon and
if you don't get it take your [ __ ]
plane and go back where the [ __ ] you you
you want to be go to Mars for all I give
a [ __ ] because the freedom of press is
different it is [ __ ] different I
don't give a [ __ ] what anyone says but
again
also the journalists don't quite
understand it either but let's listen
um so
uh no special treatment
um
and a story
um
like or trying to be clever about it
like oh I posted a link to the real-time
information because obviously uh is that
is obviously simply trying to evade the
the meaning that is there's no different
from head and paste than actually
showing real-time information
um so when you're saying posting a link
to it I mean some of the people like
Drew and and Ryan Mack uh from New York
Times who were were banned were were you
know they were reporting on it in the
course of sort of pretty normal
journalistic Endeavors
um you consider that like a tricky
attempt at band evasion
you saw the link to the real-time
information about evasion obviously I I
drew I don't think you were posting the
real-time information right I mean
you're suggesting that we're sharing
your uh address which is not not true
um and you're suggesting that we're
we're posting
and we never I I never posted your
address you posted a link to the address
we posted a link we in in the course of
reporting about Elon Jeff okay okay then
they go round and round here and there's
more other stories that Elon eventually
gets butt hurt because he can't handle
the heat and he just he leaves the room
and then he just he knew the spaces yeah
he was in there for like three and a
half minutes I want to say maybe yeah
the video is about 3 37. so basically
what happens is uh everyone continues
talking they talk to Jack Sweeney who's
the creator of Elon jet uh they're
talking to Drew they're talking to other
people and kind of getting their
perspective Katie and some and they
bring in Taylor Lorenz from uh from uh
Washington Post because she's dealt with
a lot of this which she yeah doxy well
and she she had her account was acting
weird yesterday too so right it was
unclear she was under some sort of
Shadow Banner or suspension or something
so a lot of people came in and they were
all talking and we were in there for
probably another 20 to 30 minutes and
then all of a sudden
like Katie was mid-sentence and then it
just cut out
and I was like whoa that's [ __ ] weird
like and then didn't didn't they go back
and turn the recording off like they
they asked the recorder yes luckily
people got this tape yeah yeah so you
could still access it and then it was no
longer accessible so basically if you go
to her profile or anyone else who's
sharing his Twitter space you'd be like
oh I can't see the archived version and
then a lot of me and other people were
like wait Katie what happened and she
was like uh it just ended like the app
closed on me and so what I believe
happened and the time that Elon left
because he got [ __ ] butt hurt and
acted like a [ __ ] cuck left at
Twitter space he got in touch with
someone in engineering and said hey
there's a legacy bug which there is a
bug and it allows someone who is a
permanently suspended account to go in
and still use Twitter spaces
so Elon probably went to an engineer and
say hey we got to fix this bug
immediately
and by doing so and the reason he was so
buttered and it had to be an immediate
fix that he did was because it was the
journalists that were banned permanently
suspended and banned from Twitter that
he personally was like this person's
banned and this because this wasn't an
automatic thing done through an
algorithm it was him telling somebody
through his own or or him going into the
the uh admin like super admin so there's
also different like roles of hierarchy
in a system
and there's like the admin who has
certain controls and there's like a
super admin who can do most things if
not all of them and so I wouldn't be
surprised if Elon did it himself he was
in the dashboard that was revealed
revealed in the Twitter files 3.0 or
whatever
of this dashboard that existed to like
hey you know we can look at what the
account status is of summoned and what
they tweet and where they've accessed
from and all those things right
so what I believe happened is Elon
personally went through and was like
suspended permanently suspended
permanently permanent band permanent
permanent and then what happened was he
went to an engineer and said hey we've
got this Legacy bug and the reason again
that he was so adamant of fixing it last
night was because the people that were
[ __ ] talking were the ones that he
suspended right and he didn't like that
he got [ __ ] butt hurt he found as
soon as she was like Drew you didn't
share that and he had a back and forth
withdrew another minute and then he was
like oh well I gotta boom a little
[ __ ] bounced So within 30 seconds he
had to go shut him up right so wait wait
wait wait I I just wanna before we move
on here I want to remember there was a
reason why Elon Musk bought Twitter what
was that reason there was a reason why I
bought it
it was like a main one there's like one
reason yeah like it's got a it's got
like a like a like it's an amendment I
can't really you know all his Sims you
know they get in the threads and they
say this [ __ ] it's freedom of ah what is
that freedom of
um speech is that the one yes yes oh
okay I got you so so basically
um he's a lying sack of [ __ ] just like
the rest of the right wing they don't
care about your speech they only care
about their own speech and that is why
Elon Musk was a candidate for bone of
the week but he got tucked really hard
um with this airplane and I I actually
tweeted so airplane speech isn't free
speech
airplane speech is not free speech so
Elon Musk congratulations on being the
first one to be a candidate for bone of
the week and
that's the very first time that has ever
happened Gabe Sanchez we have a
dishonorable mention and I think it's
very important to point out since we're
going to be going into the final what
seems to be the final January 6th select
hearing on Monday where they're going to
give out criminal referrals because um
this guy
is a criminal and he was sentenced today
for the crimes he committed during the
Insurrection during the Cheeto dust
kangaruku his name is Doug Jensen a lot
of people don't know that name and they
probably don't even recognize this
picture that much right this is a mug
shot yeah this is the mug oh so this is
his Federal monk shot yeah this is
mugshot okay so Doug Jensen was at the
Insurrection that day now when I show
you this video
um you're definitely going to know who
he is almost immediately
um but and Midas had it here minus touch
had it and they tweeted insurrectionist
Doug Jensen who chased officer Goodman
which uh we mentioned earlier through
the capitol during the January 6 attack
was sentenced to five years in prison
sorry about that let me let me make it
bigger and we'll play this
um this is a minute 25 seconds this is
the video showing and you'll you'll
recognize Jensen here
um as they're chasing Goodman through
the capitol this
um historic moment it's not good history
um it's bad history but it is absolutely
part of who we are now and that is what
we have to make sure we don't continue
is this to be a part of us let's watch
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
I want to pause it here you see uh
officer Goodman going up the steps this
is uh
again it's it's maddening that this
video even exists yeah
um but it does exist and it is part of
history now and it we will make them own
it forever but a Goodman here is leading
these insurrectionists through the
capital now you had mentioned this
earlier that officer Goodman had enough
sense to make sure he would lead them in
the wrong direction and what I mean by
that is a way from lawmakers that these
people would put in danger because
officer Goodman by doing that in that
moment understood that these people
wanted to harm lawmakers yeah he knew it
in the moment they were saying it to him
he he knew to protect those lawmakers
that was that's his [ __ ] job is to
protect the lawmakers and our
Constitution and that building
and he's he's a hero for doing that but
if you look down here at the bottom of
the steps let me let me move it forward
just a little bit
um and chasing him up the steps because
this is important this is where he got
sentenced to five years is because this
guy was in the front and he was chasing
Goodman right here right and he
confronts him
um this is where it gets Harry and his
indictment and his in conviction and
because Goodman's giving him orders here
and he's not complying he's chasing
Goodman and you see he's one of the only
ones chasing him of the steps here this
is why they gave uh Mr Jensen the the
Trump supporting insurrectionist the the
traitor uh as it is to our constitution
he's chasing him up the steps here
um and I want to play this but did you
have something you wanted to say there
about that oh no what I was going to say
was like you know officer Goodman the
way that I would describe the actions he
took on January 6 was very much like a
like a ring Master right like he is
someone who
knows the arena the arena being the the
capital yeah he knew the map he knew the
map yeah he knew where to go where to
avoid and the idea that he knew like all
right I got my baton here and if I you
know instigate them then they'll try to
come for me yeah I'm putting my life at
risk I understand the situation I'm
putting myself in but I also know if I
don't do this that I would allow them to
then discover other places where other
people are hiding like I don't know the
vice president or other people who are
like City members of Congress because we
clearly know
these [ __ ] Q Anon Maga Trump humping
idiots
didn't care
who was who was good or bad I mean they
were in the chambers and they were
reading papers and they misread the
[ __ ] papers they'd be like oh Ted
Cruz is gonna sell us out and they're
like oh no no no it means he was gonna
do this like they had no clear Direction
they saw a complete red because you know
Donald Trump incited the violence told
them to march the capital to show them
uh what you mean and how to represent
your voice and uh you know fight like
Hal and we're gonna kick some out all
this [ __ ] from all these [ __ ]
idiots right
and this is a moment in here where
officer Goodman knew exactly like
watched how far they had come from
outside to come inside and he's like
[ __ ] okay
this is my job I'm like in there with
the [ __ ] Bull and I've gotta like you
know draw the red cape so I can move
them through and and direct them
different ways because if I don't then
other people will be at risk well and
and just watching this back and forth as
I'm slowly moving it and kind of back
and forth and watching officer Goodman
in his tactic here you notice he comes
up he comes to the bottom of the steps
he stops he gets his baton and he pauses
right because he knows he needs time and
and if you watch this in the moment you
wouldn't know how cognitive of of all
these moments and the absolute
um importance of every second that he
holds these people off because he's got
a radio yeah he's got a radio they're
making calls he's making calls into the
radio
um so and he knows these different
location points and he he kind of knows
what's happening outside the moment of
him but this this is the example of what
law enforcement actually looks like this
is what this is what service looks like
this is what protect and serve looks
like and not protect in service of one
thyself but of the law and you see him
stop here
he goes up the steps officer Goodman
stops again to pause because he knows
they'll stop right he's already he's
already got it he already has them like
he said in a ring Master type technique
um I want to point something out so he
goes up these steps here and of course
he can't see around this corner but he
knows if you watch his face here watch
look how sure and confident
Goodman is here he doesn't look afraid
he doesn't look scared he looks very
confident in his tactics and what he's
doing and he knows exactly the [ __ ]
assignment here is to make sure these
morons these violent morons do not get
anywhere near our the Constitutional
duty of lawmakers because that is one
thing that officer Goodman understood in
the moment the most important thing was
not not necessarily not necessarily the
lives of people but necessarily what
those lives mean to our country people
don't understand as much as you may hate
politicians as much as you may have
hatred of who represents you
and you may not be agree with everything
they agree on they our our voice in the
government and that is how this works
and without those voices the
Constitution falls apart
and the the simple oath
the simple oath that officer Goodman
made
on the Constitution
he made good this In This Moment by
absolutely understanding that it was
more important that these people did not
undermine that document than it was
anything else and watch his confidence
as he goes up the stairs here and he
turns around again because he pauses he
needs time and every second counts Doug
has Doug Jensen here has shifted because
he was going forward and wasn't
expecting him to turn around he's like
oh okay okay
so let's back up and let's let's watch
this a bit more
um because at this moment when he comes
to the top of this stairwell this is a
pivotal moment and the reason why it's a
pivotal moment is because at the top of
these stairs
um if these people go One Direction they
are going to run and do lawmakers and uh
Goodman knows that this could be very
bad for people's lives and it's going to
put people's lives at risk not just not
just the lawmakers but the
insurrectionist because these law
enforcement agents are going to have to
use deadly forces if they have to like
they did with Ashley Babbitt if they if
these people do not do not stop the
violence and do not stop their push so
let's watch this
[Music]
[Music]
and there's the moment where officer
Goodman duped the easily duped sheep if
you if you pay attention closely when
officer Goodman comes to the top of the
stairs he stops them now when he looks
down this quarter because that is where
the lawmakers are down this Corridor
they are just steps away from that
quarter and if you officer Goodman peers
down the hallway to make sure there's no
one visibly in that hallway because he
knows if these [ __ ] violent Maga
Nazis these traitors to our [ __ ]
government these people who were duped
by Q Anon and whatever forces that
caused them to do this stupid [ __ ] that
got the that got dug here five years in
prison knew if they saw someone down
that hallway that they would turn and go
down that hallway so he made sure before
he allowed them up them steps that there
was no one in the hallway here
um and you'll you'll see that he looks
down the hallway and then he blocks the
doorway because he does not want them to
go in that hallway and then he he
physically touches Mr Jensen and to make
him agitated to make him follow him
brilliant brilliant in the moment and
such such a heroic move to make sure
this entire crowd because Jensen is the
one leading this ground that's why I got
five years
to make sure this entire crowd follows
him in the direction that is not putting
lawmakers in danger and you see him they
take the beat and let's let's finish
here because here soon is the iconic
moment where Goodman is standing in the
hallway with his hand up to stop these
people from going down the quarters
watch
this is
yeah
we're standing here for breakfast
and he finally got reinforcements
um and that and that is why Mr
um Jensen
Doug Jensen is our dishonorable mention
this week and there's so many more we
could put on this list for the same
reason Doug Jensen's on this list
um but officer Goodman is a hero he led
those insurrectionists into a corridor
and into an Atrium where other law
enforcement could give them backup keep
them away from lawmakers and keep our
constitution alive yeah keep our
Constitution and our government and our
democracy alive so thank you officer
Goodman and [ __ ] you Doug Jensen [ __ ]
you I think you should have got way more
than five years but hey five years in a
federal pen because you decided uh the
orange Mussolini Jesus should be your
dictator I guess good luck to you but
also on the on the last note there Doug
Jensen is a q Anon belief like he's
literally wearing a cute shirt right and
I believe I saw a quote I think a
statement or or something revealing like
the motivation of why he did those
things because he wanted Q Anon
to be the thing that was the driving
force like he wanted people to know that
it was Q
which
it's so [ __ ] dumb it's insane
it's insane and you know what's crazy is
we come full circle here on bone end of
the week because
not only did we have Doug Jensen using Q
Anon we have Ron DeSantis peddling q9
conspiracy theories Elon Musk 100
percent buys into Q Anon no doubt in my
mind and then you have Donald J Trump
the Cheeto dust q and honor so Gabe
Sanchez Gabe Sanchez you know I asked
this every week who is the winner of
this week's bonehead of the week
Donald J Trump the Cheeto dust q and
honor wins bonehead of the week of
course there's a lot of reasons why this
guy could be on this pole this week but
there's only one obvious reason why he
would win now we were unsure about this
right because we had Elon on the pole
which the polls on Twitter and he won
the Twitter poll right yeah he won the
Twitter poll he won the Twitter poll but
Donald Trump pulled it out on the
YouTube side of the poll because you can
vote on YouTube or on Twitter yeah but
the reason why Donald Trump made it
on this week's bone end of the week is
because
he is really butt hurt that dark Brandon
has better means than him I truly
believe that's exactly what it is but he
turned it into another Griff Gabe
Sanchez he turned it into a Griff tell
us about the nft Griff that he decided
that was a major announcement this week
yeah so Donald Trump said there's going
to be a major announcement on December
15th it's coming there right and he had
a video that had him with a [ __ ]
laser eyes and
busting open this chest like he was a
[ __ ] oh we're gonna play it oh we're
gonna play it
and the and the the special big and
big individual trading cards nfts
and the funny thing I mean there's a lot
of funny things about this but the funny
thing is
people could purchase a a an nft right
but they did not have a choice as to
which card digital card they were given
he's like oh they're like trading cards
like baseball cards like collect them
all like [ __ ] Pokemon or some [ __ ] I
like poke it down or something like I
saw someone that said that called it a
broken mon I made it where it was I call
it Trump Pokemon is what I call Pokemon
yeah but okay yeah you went with the
longer version
I went with the I just played into the P
now somebody commented broke him on and
I was like that's pretty good yeah it's
a good one that's a good one that's a
good one so here is here is the um let
me play this for the special
announcement yeah this is the
announcement for the announcement yeah
um and this is what got um the right
wing mangas kind of upset because he did
this and then didn't really do a major
announcement but let's listen to the
sizzle reel America needs a superhero
foreign
[Music]
okay just the the trailer Sizzle reel
whatever you announcement of the
announcer whatever you want to call this
oh my God what I I again I I brought
this up yesterday or the day but it was
yesterday we had Rachel bitter cover on
the show and if you want to go watch
that you can it was great
but we have former presidents one of
them in particular Jimmy Carter he has
Habitat for Humanity that is his that is
his that his his former president Legacy
right George W bush he's a painter
Clinton is a Clinton Foundation Obama's
done a lot of documentaries in the last
few years like really a groundbreaking
great documentaries are producing a lot
of great films
um so uh Bush and Obama decided art
um and then they have an Obama
foundation too but Clinton's decided to
to put their their work into the Clinton
Foundation Jimmy Carter decided to build
houses for people who could not afford
them and when I say he built houses
President Jimmy Carter when he was the
former president literally went to these
houses and built him with his bare
[ __ ] hands Gabe Sanchez to this day
in his 90s Jimmy Carter is still showing
up at these projects and building houses
for people who cannot afford housing
with his bare hands
and the former president Donald Trump
is selling digital trading cards and
this is the major announcement here is
the um let me find it here here's the
here's the actual this is the
infomercial what's hilarious about this
and I've watched this
a couple times
um since the other day and I'm like
it was yesterday it feels like it feels
like a week ago man yeah I know it does
it feels like a we go so here's the
thing because we went through the
website and everything yesterday so if
you want to see us going through the
website like all the how to enter and
we're going to talk about it here but
how to enter like the contest and and
there no purchase necessary we did that
yesterday on the show you go watch that
on the dirty Michael's podcast
um just subscribe to YouTube channel you
can find it there but this video here it
really does feel like he had none of
this written
they're just like yeah just say whatever
you want in the camera this should be
great yeah just talk about it off the
cuff it'll be great let's listen to the
infomercial
it's better than the sizzle reel really
honestly let's watch
hello everyone this is Donald Trump
hopefully your favorite President of all
time better than Lincoln better than
Washington with an important
announcement to make
oh God hopefully hopefully hopefully I
wanna I wanna be humble I want to be
humble hopefully
hopefully uh you think I'm uh I'm your
I'm your favorite uh uh president but uh
hopefully uh you know I can Gabe Sanchez
I can guarantee you one thing yeah that
that Abe Lincoln and George Washington
would never never
consider themselves so highly of
themselves that they would release nft
Trump trading guards our trading cards
in general about quote their life and
experience which none of them have
anything to do with his libraries
experience this guy has tried so many
griffs he sells gold coins he's he's
partnered with [ __ ] 401K programs on
Newsmax he's got a Donald Trump uh
child's like history kind of book which
isn't really history but all right uh
uh he's got the collect Trump cards he's
got the
um what's the other one I mean he had
Trump University Trump I mean like
post-presidency oh okay so all these are
griffs now they do oh look at the emails
you get the emails from them even yeah
and yeah the emails I get text messages
from him and Don Jr really desperate
text messages
um yeah and even before that like a lot
of people are like oh why do you think
this would be any different steaks water
[ __ ] the airline uh the game the
board game that he had all of these
things
failed they [ __ ] failed failed failed
failed he had an idea he's a loser
complete loser
where what he does is he takes a
relatively cheap product he slaps his
name on it or he has another like a
luxury item slaps his name on it and
says people will definitely buy this
because it has my name Trump on it and
what he found was a lot of people in
these situations you're like well no I
can buy my [ __ ] steaks from Omaha
Steaks I can buy my water from [ __ ]
mountain springs or Mountain ice or
whatever I can buy my plane travel from
all of the other airlines he thinks that
his name will go far and Far Far for all
of these people to be like oh yeah Trump
is my go-to and screw my like go-to
alternative here Trump is going to be
the one that I actually double down on
but what he finds is any for every
single one all of them have gone defunct
they've either filed for bankruptcy or
they've they've failed to launch or
whatever it might be and since he's
since he's gone out of the presidency
Beyond him stealing documents he's tried
to grift money based on people paying
for his jet which he never actually got
a new jet these cards gold
um
uh what else oh you name it he's done it
well that's and that's the point and
that's the point here
um and you see the image on here he's
even put his face on Mount Rushmore here
which people which people need to
understand too these images which
actually he'll talk about it
but these all of these images these nfts
that are created are based on uh his
career and his life yeah well let's
let's let's see let's see if if that's
correct because it shows a few more
images in this video I'm doing my first
official Donald J Trump nft collection
right here and right now they're called
Trump digital trading cards these cards
feature some of the really incredible
artwork pertaining to my life and my
career it's been very exciting he was an
astronaut did you see that he was an
astronaut did you see him did you see
him in that little uh that tux right
there because I'm pretty sure if someone
were to Google Trump Queen tux they
would see an image where he was like
almost busting out of the [ __ ] scenes
right very different than that image
right well very different the other
thing that I want to point out here
is
that
trading cards in general when I was a
kid Michael Jordan was very popular and
I said this in the beginning of the show
and I collected Michael Jordan cards you
probably did too you were from Chicago
they do not look trading cards do not
look like this normally they have like a
border they've got like the name the
position maybe the year that it is they
got the theme the team that they play
for maybe or something maybe maybe it's
a special event maybe it's like they
scored a certain amount of points in
this game or they're a defensive player
of the year or contestant you know
candidate of the Year something
something about that series of the
trading cards none of that just just
absolute lies about Trump in any
situation or experience that he might
have it's it's insanity and I'd love to
play the rest of you but I I I I don't
think I'm going there's one there's one
point
I don't care about the rest of the video
okay sounds like an idiot what I do want
to say here is that all right it's
called Trump digital trading cards okay
trading cards I haven't really seen many
people talk about this point trading
cards
that means that you have to trade them
okay when you get an nft when you buy an
NFP you know through blockchain uh
typically people hold on to those
there's not a lot of training that
happens like sure you could transfer
ownership if you want but you just paid
for this card which by the way
I guess in a sense it is like a trading
card because when you buy a pack of
cards you don't know what's in there
and in the same way when you buy nft on
this thing because they're sold out now
but when you could buy an nft on this
you gotta randomly generated image now I
don't know what random AI photoshopped
dumb
trading card you were given but you did
not you you could not choose
the other thing too is some people
couldn't even access it right some
people could because here's the thing
you had to you had to sign up with your
email put your credit card then you had
a you know you have a digital wallet
because it's based on ethereum which is
a uh it's anyway
all of this stuff was under the idea
that people would know what it was
people would understand how to make it
work right the if you can't get people
to access this or access their wallet
how do you imagine that someone's going
to be able to trade this with someone
because that's the other part of this is
like again it's a trading card how am I
supposed to find other people who are
the [ __ ] collectors where do I go to
find these people do I just put up a
post to say hey I'm one of the idiots
that bought these cards because that's
what it is someone's gonna have to make
a website where it's like here's a
database of users go go register as an
owner right and it's like hey uh I
bought a digital trading card I was
scammed I'm an idiot because well that's
what they're saying and the other thing
too is because this thing is held inside
of a a wallet and that sort of thing is
apparently they're charging them to
actually transfer it
they're charging them they're charging
them to transfer it so they're making
money not just on the purse purchase but
the transfer of it if you're
transferring now 10 they make on the
sale
right and in perpetuity it's not just
you transferred over it's every single
time right every single time it's sold
any ink or whatever the company nft Inc
LLC or some [ __ ] [ __ ] well here's
the thing about that company apparently
because we were reading through the
rules and reading through the terms the
other day because we were trying to
figure out if we wanted to enter the
sweepstakes so I could go to Mar-A-Lago
and have a personal meeting with Donald
Trump and 6 000 other people who weren't
in the contest or some [ __ ]
because they had to zoom once we watched
that Rhonda Santa's clip I kind of think
that's what that's what it's going to be
like well it might be but we want I
would like to
go or at least enter and to win this
this sweepstakes I think it would be
brilliant to um to win this thing uh me
the Tony Michaels win the sweepstakes to
go meet Donald Trump that would be
hilarious
um but here's the thing we were looking
for the rules there's an address for
this nft LLC it's all [ __ ]
and it's the same golf course that he
gives the it's the address is the same I
guess as one of the address that the
golf course uses that he's giving away
the Sweepstakes on because there's
certain golf things where you can go
golfing with them or I don't know it's a
whole golf game or you get to stand
there and he'll pose his cardboard
cutout we'll pose with you with his
thumbs up on the golf I'm not sure what
the [ __ ] prize is the point is is
that it has to do with the Palm Beach
golf course but the nft LLC the company
that's running this thing apparently has
one of the same address that the golf
course uses for business so it seems to
be
that's suspicious but it seems like if
that's the truth if that is that if if
we can get clarification on that fact
that would mean that Donald Trump is
possibly licensing his name to himself
because that's what this is right but
that's no different than him buying his
own and bidding on the own items that's
right on his own items from the
foundation you mean you mean you mean
laundering charity money is that what
you mean
because that's that's right and that's
that's what I believe is happening here
because what happened yesterday within a
12-hour block
you're gonna tell me that 45
000 of these digital trading cards were
sold because now when you go to the
website they say sold out sold out it's
all sold out because of course a digital
asset can't be replicated but he said
sold out 45 000 because he's you know
president 45. there's not 45 000 that
were sold out that's what he's got and
he says 45 000 sold at 99 which means
that 4.45 million dollars was made on
the backs of these Trump idiots
but I don't honestly think that that
many items were sold even if one person
bought one because I don't know why you
need more than one but who knows uh even
if 45 individual people bought them I
still wouldn't believe it in 12 hours
that is not no that does not happen that
is not something that would happen
especially for people who do not know
anything about crypto or getting a
digital wallet or people who bought it
and now we're like well I don't know how
to access this [ __ ] because of course
it's difficult because they make it hard
and they try to make money on you to
transfer or sell it back to someone or
whatever it is but
I do not believe that 4.45 million
dollars was made in a 12-hour period
from a guy who has to sell [ __ ] nfts
to pay off legal fees because he broke
all of these laws and he's a legal team
to pay to defend him to say yes Donald
Trump took these documents okay but he
believes they were his like
he's he's grifting money off a bunch of
idiots and I don't think that in 12
hours 45
000 digital trading cards were sold what
I think happened is maybe some people
bought them maybe like a few thousand
people Max Max maybe maybe 10 000 Max no
way more than that okay let's give him
20. let's give him 20. that means that
25 000 were just up in the air somewhere
and what I believe happened is they had
some third-party shell Company by with
Trump's money probably Trump supporters
money that he grifted off of them and
they used to buy 25
000 so you're buying two point two
million or so dollars worth of digital
trading cards again the [ __ ] trading
cards now he owns his own trading card
now he owns his own
but I would believe that there's some
sort of I don't know money laundering
aspect to this to why absolutely why
this I think I think that's what the
whole scam is in front of the mill [ __ ]
that he does I think that's why they
only did a certain amount because
because they have to have a finite
amount so that they can trade them with
inside the wallet so they can make money
and he doesn't wander the money through
other money that he's grifted other
places launder it through here to get it
back into his pocket there for the
licensing fee which he owns the
licensing contract and he owns the
company that owns the licensing contract
so basically he's taken all his money
and he's filtering it through to put it
back in his pocket you know what that's
what he's always doing
that reminds me of someone else who was
on bonehead of the week this week which
was Elon Musk now Elon Musk end of last
year he made a charity donation of like
5.6 billion or something like that
but it was revealed yesterday or two
days ago that uh the charity because he
didn't disclose where it went but then
tax other documents were revealed and we
found out that it was actually a charity
that he's affiliated with his charity
and then 4.5 billion of that was just a
write-off right so again he just be
through it's the same type of stuff
that's happening here you're going to
have a third-party company that buys a
bunch of these assets then you find a
devaluation in in the value or of the
asset and then they say okay well I lost
money on the on the purchase so now I'm
going to use this to uh file a uh like a
file for like a deduction or file for
savings on my taxes like that is the way
that they work here and that is the way
that Trump Works he Griff's money he
finds some loophole trying to con Play
Con people and then when it comes to you
know tax season he's like oh well
actually I lost money guys right I lost
money uh through the company that I
owned to buy the assets that I was
selling to people to purchase to pay off
my legal bills and crazy stuff that's
the this is an insane timeline that we
live in we it hey we are at the
intersection of WrestleMania in real
life and let me give you a couple really
bad photoshops to prove it to you
um this is one of the best memes that
came out of this whole thing you see
Donald Trump here with the wrestling
belt on and again I've been saying this
for years we're at the intersection of
WrestleMania in real life and Trump
proves it to me right out in the open uh
this means says this is basically the
same as this these two photoshops are
kind of the same wait wait wait that's
part of Hillary Clinton is not real hey
Trump supporters do you see how [ __ ]
weird this is now it's really [ __ ]
weird it's really weird you douche okay
remember Donald Trump said all of these
digital trading cards all of them were
based on his life and his career so
remind me when one Mount Rushmore was
added his base term despite the fact
that Christy Noam purchased uh
or whatever for a fake Mount Rushmore
that he has in Mar-A-Lago tell me the
time that Trump went into a boxing ring
tell me the time that Trump went into a
wrestling ring dressed as a superhero
tell me the time that Trump was an
astronaut uh tell me or John Wayne or I
mean it could go on and on and on
there's so many of these did he write an
elephant no
um Becky sued JoJo from Jersey's
character said riding a motorcycle in
outer space which is hilarious videos
you could watch it we played it earlier
but and it's not surprising that Donald
Trump was our bonehead of the week
because of this boneheaded move and I'm
sure there's going to be more
bone-headed re uh stuff about this story
as we find out that yes this is not only
Griff this is a Monday launderings game
as it always is with Donald Trump Gabe
Sanchez let's give the winner
his due
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh well this week is the bone end of the
week of the Q and honors and the Cheeto
dust q and honor comes out on top he
wins the poll a bonehead of the week
this is the bone of the week is every
single Friday here on the Tony Michaels
podcast in the Midas touch Network make
sure to go follow us on the Tony
Michaels podcast Gabe Sanchez that is
how you vote for Mona of the week go to
the community tab on YouTube you can
vote there you can also vote on elon's
Twitter at Tony Michaels pod just don't
give his airplane location away you
might not be able to vote if you do that
and if you're on the money's touch
Network right now watching the clip
subscribe to the minus touch Network and
download every single episode of our
podcast the Tony Michaels podcast but
also bonehead the week on Sundays you go
to Apple Spotify Google your favorite
directory
and make sure while you're there
subscribing to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your favorite directory you leave us
a great review and also do not want to
fail to mention again the Ron DeSantis
can go [ __ ] himself go to store.d Tony
michaels.com he was a contestant this
week on bonehead so tell him properly
how to go [ __ ] himself coffee mugs
t-shirts sweaters store not the Tony
michaels.com Gabe Sanchez that is the
bonehead of the week everyone on the
podcast stick around we got a few
announcements
but everyone of mine is touch we'll see
you next week bone of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
Gabe Sanchez bonehead of the week I got
a few announcements I want to make we
went long today we're at three hours and
15 minutes my friend
you were having some technical
difficulties
[Music]
it happens I hope that the audience
forgives me yeah for what I had to put
them through which was just more of Tony
talking
oh [ __ ] God damn okay so here here's the
few announcements I want to have on
Monday uh for for those who are still
there Monday we will be at our normal
time but we will be doing the hearing
coverage so we'll be here on this
channel and the Midas touch channel so
make sure that you be looking for the
link or you come here to this channel we
will be airing that the in its entirety
here live uh for that January 6th um
Committee hearing where they are going
to apparently give the criminal
referrals and vote on them in the
committee
um and we will start that at our our
normal time noon Eastern and we will
start the pre-coverage for that hearing
which will start at one Eastern and
we'll do an hour before we will do the
hearing and then do some time after so
join us on Monday also next week I I
misspoke when I said next week bone of
the week because next week we are off a
four day weekend for Christmas so we
will have a poll yeah we will not have
the video because we will be off Friday
and Monday for Christmas so everyone
mark it in your calendars you're gonna
find something else to do for a couple
hours maybe go watch one of the old
maybe go watch the old one
huh
I said spend some time with your family
I know you got to go watch an old
episode of ours so don't for don't
forget to subscribe presents just listen
to Gabe and tell him that's right that's
right don't forget to subscribe here on
YouTube uh so you can go watch an old
episode on Friday you can also go to
Twitter follow at Tony Michaels POD at
the Tony Michaels and at I am Gabe
Sanchez unless I get you know
spicy this afternoon decided to start
posting Elon Musk assassination location
[ __ ] idiot um also download every
single episode for us do us a favor go
to Apple Spotify Google your favorite
directory and download every single
episode of the Tony Michaels podcast
leave us a great review while you're
there if you're on the minus touch
Facebook page don't forget to follow us
at the Tony Michaels and again we're
gonna see you on Monday we're see I'm
it's gonna be a little different because
it is the hearing on Monday but it
should be interesting
um and I and we'll be putting out that
link very soon this afternoon uh for you
to uh if you want to go to the minus
touch networks Channel or if you want to
stay here you can you can watch the
hearing here at the Johnny Michaels
podcast have a great safe weekend Gabe
Sanchez figure out your camera for
Monday all right I will okay everybody
Surfside [ __ ] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn head ass Beacon